Hallo Chatge.
abonnieren, um Drops zu verdienen.
Kann man das nicht wegmachen?
Moin.
So, Leute, ihr seht vielleicht,
wobei, ne, ihr seht nicht, weil es sind genau drei Leute da.
Ich warte
nochmal kurz.
Aber egal, ich sag's halt einfach fünfmal, ist auch
egal. Ich hab Windows neu installiert, Leute.
Und
das Schlimmste
ist,
meine ganzen Tabs sind weg.
Irgendwie hat das mein Chromium nicht gecheckt, dass ich ihn umgezogen habe und jetzt sind meine 800 Tabs weg.
Nicht, dass es jetzt so super schlimm wäre, aber...
Sackt.
Oh, das müssen wir ein bisschen größer machen.
Aber OBS und so, es müsste alles funktionieren.
Also die Katz ist da, der Chat ist da.
Lautstärke müsste so ungefähr
passen, denke ich.
Windows und Sound Settings ist ja immer so.
Ist ja, ne, so ein Ding für sich.
Settings hier unten,
es müsste eigentlich alles hinhauen.
Also ich sollte mich im besten Fall
anhören, wie immer.
Sieht aufgeräumt, nicht lange.
Sieht nicht lange aufgeräumt aus.
Übrigens, ich bin begeistert, ne,
wie gut dieses
Teil hier für Bilder
overlay und und und sounds noch funktioniert das ist ein das ist ein
ding was wir programmiert haben in dotnet framework 4.6 1 rf programmer das
kenne ich das kenne ich das für sp 32 dinger das kenne ich das habe ich sogar
schon mal ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher
zumindest hat die erkennung auch nicht funktioniert
ja hat nicht funktioniert das ist auf jeden fall nicht nicht besser als chat
GPT im Icon und Chat GPT
sagt auch.
Ja, Tabs sind weg.
Zedge.
Wisst ihr, was mir da gerade auffällt?
Chat, wartet mal. Kann das sein?
Wartet mal.
Wollen wir ausprobieren. Irgendwie sinnloses
Emo. Moment, ich habe keine Emotes
hier in meinem Chat. Was ist da los?
Ach so.
Ha. Bei der Windows-Installation
FFZ
muss ich ja noch installieren.
Ohne FFZ geht das nicht.
Download Google Chrome.
Ja.
Hinzufügen.
Weiterung hinzufügen.
Ja.
FFZ muss installiert werden.
Gut.
So und jetzt. Moment.
Hier. Pin.
Reload.
Hat das jetzt alles hier
ffz kontrollzentrum funktioniert exzellent so okay aber die wir haben die
emotes alles alles passt das lasst mal kurz lasst mal kurz bisschen sinnlos
zeug spam haben wir denn hier beispielsweise
Dertke.
Doch, 7TV-Emote sollte auch drin sein.
Xding.
Was?
Moment.
Keine...
Das geht nicht.
Twitch Wobblons.
Sekunde, das muss gefixt werden.
Also...
Okay, geil.
Jetzt krieg ich erstmal Red Bull Werbung oder sowas bei mir auf dem Channel.
Äh, hallo.
Browser ist kaputt
Macht nix mehr
Gefreest
Ups, ah
Was hab ich jetzt gemacht
Ich find das auch geil
Hier Windows, ne
Du kannst hier nicht einfach beenden
Das geht nicht
Du musst erst sagen
Start without your data
Und dann
Fuck mich nicht ab
Microsoft
Alter
No
Und das da oben soll auch weg
Alter, wie kann man dieses
Weiß jemand, wie man diesen Mist hier oben
wegklickt? Ich will da nicht draufklicken
Können
Okay, nochmal
Chat
Okay
Zack, Chat
Der Browser ist schon wieder gefreest
Alter, was ist das denn?
warum warum warum warum ist der browser so abkacken wo blos chat moment moment
moment wo bloß moment moment das wichtigste habe ich ja ganz vergessen
you block origin light ich brauche ja noch hier adblocker
geht bei den einstellungen vom desktop hintergrund da
vermutlich
ok wo bloß chat
Okay
Was? Warum ist da eine Werbung?
Die Werbung freest
meinen Browser
Was zum Teufel
ist das?
Okay, Chat
Wummelwanz
Gucken, ob Synchromium funktioniert
Alter, nervt nicht
Das freest auch?
What the fuck?
Die dreckige Twitch-Schreibung
freest meinen Browser.
Das kannst du doch keinem erzählen.
Das kannst du doch wirklich...
Also...
Das heißt, du hast auch den Bug.
Okay, pass mal auf Firefox.
firefox
wisst ihr was mich auch bei aktuellen
anwendungen übelst abfuckt
dass die immer bevor du was machen kannst
30 milliarden popups haben
woblords chat
moment moment
ublock origin firefox
hier muss ich ja noch installieren
hab ich ja alles noch nicht gemacht
hier nach der windows 9 installation
hinzufügen
also hier für den stream account
für meinen anderen account schon
ok wo bloß chat sehr intelligente high IQ Chat 80 plus IQ Chat schafft ihr das
heute auch oder heute nicht es ist heute 80
alter ich raste aus ich habe es gedacht sogar firefox ist ja ok chat
das bringt mir ja nix aber warte mal jetzt jetzt pfeiffert pfeiffert modus
Ich will es ja gar nicht so, hier
Nein, nein, nein, das muss weg
Chat, Chat, Popout
Hier, warte mal
Wir gehen auf Twitch, nein, nein, nein
Das, okay, das ist wieder
Es ist wieder deutlich komplexer, als ich mir das vorgestellt habe
Wir gehen, wir gehen random auf Twitch
Ist mir egal, wo so
Dann gehe ich jetzt in irgendeinen Chat
Hier rein, ja
Genau, hier irgendwo random bei irgendwelchen Leuten
Da gehen wir jetzt in Chat
Dann gehen wir hier auf FFZ
Kontrollzentrum
Addons
Ähm
So, 7TV Emotes aktivieren
Better Twitch TV Emotes aktivieren
Und ich glaube das war's
So, jetzt gehen wir wieder in meinen Chat
Und jetzt
Sollten wir
Alter
Was ist das?
Jetzt freest schon, wenn man den Chat einfach aufmacht
Was zum Teufel ist denn hier kaputt gerade?
Okay, wir schalten erstmal dieses komische auf dem Hintergrund klicken aus
Wo geht dann das auszuschalten?
Der Browser ist wipecoded
Weiß jemand, wo man diesen Mist hier hinten ausschaltet?
Okay, Windows-Logik
Wo könnte das sein?
Background
Personalize your background
Windows Spotlight
Picture
Ah, jetzt ist es weg
Okay
location has been turned off ja das ist ja auch gut so got it
das ist ja auch keine location will ich auch die location liegen
komm mal gibt es pringles sieht aus wie pringles oder
ok so das lassen wir jetzt einfach so jetzt ist dieser mist aus und jetzt
hoffe ich dass irgendwie mein chat einfach funktioniert chat please ffz im aus testen
und sonst im ort sind am start jetzt alles gut
alter ob es falsch ist egal geschafft schwierigste sache vom stream erledigt
auch die ffz beste extension für twitch ok ok wichtigstes wichtigstes erledigt windows settings
Übrigens, wie krass hässlich ist eigentlich diese komische Taskbar seit Windows 25 H2?
Das ist überhaupt nicht einheitlich.
Die Dinge hier sind unterschiedlich groß und verändern ihre Größe teilweise im laufenden Betrieb und sowas.
Das ist ganz abartig.
Wie eklig haben sie diese Taskleiste eigentlich gemacht?
Ach ja, by the way, ich kann jetzt übrigens Battlefield spielen.
Deswegen habe ich ja Windows neu installiert.
Ich hab jetzt Secure Boot an
Und ich hab
Ey, Secure Boot, oder?
Das war's
Deswegen läuft, genau, deswegen läuft Anti-Cheat
Secure Boot
Hab ich am Start
So, und meine VM
Ist auch am Start, guckt euch das mal an
Aber die VM, die muss eindeutig
Rebooted werden
Windows 10 war viel besser
Leute, Windows XP
SP3
war Peak.
Battlefield 3 Videos,
Adventure und Battlefield 6 Videos.
Guck mal, wir haben jetzt Doppelte. Wir haben Battlefield 3
mal 2 quasi jetzt.
So, da sind wir.
Es gibt übrigens einen Bug,
habe ich gefunden in Windows.
Was heißt einen?
Also,
Also, es gibt sicherlich viele Bugs, aber einer, der mir besonders auf den Keks geht, sagen wir es mal so.
Ihr habt es ja gesehen, ich habe das hier in der VM, meinen Linux.
Aber das Desktop-Switchen aus der VM funktioniert beim ersten Fullscreen-Machen der VM nicht.
Dazu muss ich einmal raus-tappen in Task Manager und dann funktioniert es wieder.
Warum? Keine Ahnung.
Man weiß es nicht.
Ach ja, und diese hässliche Leiste hier oben kann man auch nicht ausblenden.
Ist auch geil, oder?
Guckt, seht ihr das?
Die Leiste ist immer ein Stückchen da.
Immer.
Ob ich das will oder nicht?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das vielleicht...
Vielleicht kann man das ja irgendwie umstellen.
Kann man das umstellen?
Wollen wir mal ausprobieren.
4M?
Ne, das müsste Preferences sein.
Hier irgendwo global.
Wo könnte das sein, dass man diese komische Leiste, dass die ausgeblendet wird?
microsoft file mit almost all major windows 11 features abrocknen
ok das war ich mir klar wo könnte man wo könnte man diese komische komische leiste
die der ein und ausgeblendet wird wo könnte man das hier nicht wo könnte das sein input
Ne
Hotkeys
Display
Menü und Toolbar
Use the single button
Combine
Ah, guck mal hier
Schau Toolbar Edge when unpinned in fullscreen
Okay
Das wollen wir ja nicht
Jetzt ist sie weg
So ist das gut
Nice
Exzellent, Leute
So, jetzt muss man das hier angucken
Microsoft File
Also, alle
Haupt- oder Main-Features
Haupt-Features
von Windows 11 sind
Das ist gut
Ja
Wann was programmierst du privat aktuell?
Micro-Controller
Grams ab und zu, immer mal wieder
Just for fun
Nix, wo ich irgendwas bei rausbekommen will
Microcontroller
Ich habe hier ein ESP32
So ein Ding habe ich hier gerade liegen
ESP32
Mit einem Display
Und da bastel ich schon seit Monaten immer mal wieder
So ein bisschen drauf rum
Kann man seine C++ Skills
Verbessern
Nichts worauf man stolz sein müsste
Schlimmste Sprache überhaupt
So, also, was ist denn hier eigentlich kaputt?
Microsoft gibt zu, dass das alles Schrott ist in Windows 11
Okay
Äh, was ist die Essenz dieses Artikels?
windows has issues ja das wissen wir auch schon lange oder chat höre ich mich heute
normal an so wie immer weil ich bin mir bei windows sound settings immer nicht sicher
ob das alles hingekriegt hat.
Was sagt ihr? Ist das so wie immer?
Passt das?
Weil wie gesagt,
Windows Sound Settings ist so ein Ding,
die ist...
Hörst dich etwas
erkält? Ja gut, das liegt aber nicht an Windows Sound Settings.
Nö,
das liegt daran,
dass ich das liegt daran dass mir spaß macht außerdem bin ich ja kein
anwendungsentwickler hauptberuflich
zu
übrigens gab was lustig ist letzten sauf der arbeit wir hatten aber ich muss
darf jetzt nicht so viele sachen gleichzeitig machen sonst ist es habe
ich wollte mir den artikel mal kurz durchlesen was ist das was ist das
probleme windows 11 after provisioning pc mit windows 11 das hat man doch schon
explorer crash shell crash startmenü crash
funktioniert ja alles nicht system settings crash application crash exploring running but
notas bar window alles aber ganz ehrlich microsoft hat zumindest das mein gefühl
ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht also mein gefühl ist microsoft hat überhaupt
keinen fokus mehr und windows windows läuft bei microsoft irgendwie so
nebenbei gefühlt keine ahnung kümmern sich da irgendwie 15 leute oder so drum
und schuss dann irgendwas zusammen was hinten und vorne nicht zusammen passt
und versuchen es irgendwie am Laufen zu halten.
Also so wirkt das auf mich.
Die haben überhaupt keinen Fokus mehr auf Windows.
Und die haben auch übrigens keinen Fokus mehr,
also kommt mir so vor, auf Office.
Die haben ihr Office 365, ja, okay.
Aber die benutzen nur noch die ganzen Produkte, um AI zu pushen.
Das ist mein Eindruck aktuell von Microsoft.
Also egal, was das ist, ob Windows, ob Office,
die pushen zwei Sachen, das ist AI und ihre Cloud.
Der Rest ist eigentlich nur noch Mittel zum Zweck, um die zwei Sachen zu pushen.
So kommt mir Microsoft aktuell vor.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht.
Das fängt ja schon damit an, dass die, was ja im Business Enterprise Umfeld
total auf ganz viele Fans stößt,
dass die Outlook, das alte Outlook abschaffen wollen,
mit diesem neuen Outlook, was nichts kann.
Das kannst du halt im Enterprise Umfeld komplett vergessen.
Es gibt Unternehmen, die leben von Outlook-Plugins im Endeffekt.
Also ich meine jetzt nicht, dass sie die verkaufen, sondern die Abläufe in manchen Unternehmen funktionieren nur mit speziellen Outlook-Plugins.
Und das kannst du halt im neuen Outlook nicht machen.
Microsoft says it's working on a fix. Ja, das machen sie ja immer.
Du musst alles ausschalten, dass überhaupt Windows noch funktioniert.
PowerShell Scripts
has been shared
was den Explorer blockt
um zu früh zu starten
damit die anderen Sachen kaputt gehen
meine Güte ist das
Zeug im Arsch man
gibt es da eigentlich Comments zu
wo Leute keck
wie Windows schreiben
ok
Comments
sind nicht erlaubt
gibt es nicht
Thunderbird kann letztendlich Outlook Kalender in native unterstützen.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Also ich habe ja ein Office 365 Abo.
Aber, muss dazu sagen, aber ich habe das gar nicht so sehr, weil ich großer Office Fan
bin.
Ihr wisst, ich benutze so gut wie nie Office.
Also für nichts.
Ich benutze weder Word noch Excel noch sonst was.
Das einzige, was ich ab und zu mal benutze, gezwungenermaßen ist Powerpoint.
aber ich habe den office 365 abo damals abgeschlossen hauptsächlich für die zwei
terabyte cloud speicher und das war relativ günstig an nämlich eine andere kram also mit
dabei so jetzt mal updates hier in der fuß jetzt hier updates ach so ist die musik zu laut
Ja und wenn wir Updates machen, kann ich euch was lustiges erzählen.
Letztens auf der Arbeit ist morgens das Monitoring angeschlagen und hat gemeint,
aufgrund der produktiven Kiste, wird der RAM knapp.
Habe ich auch, glaube ich, schon auf Twitter gepostet.
Der RAM wird knapp.
Da haben wir uns so gefragt, hä?
Warum wird da auf einmal der RAM knapp?
Normalerweise ist das so eine komplett unauffällige Kiste,
auf der passiert einfach jahrelang nichts und die läuft halt einfach.
warum wird da der RAM auf einmal knapp? Was ist da los?
Haben wir uns
drauf eingeloggt und Chat
ratet mal, was
ein Großteil des RAMs gefüllt
hat.
Also das ist, das ist eine
Admin-Kiste für
Datenbank-Admins. So,
kann man das sagen. Benutzen die so als
Jump-Host für
Datenbank-Gedöns.
Und die Kiste
hat, glaube ich, auch
nur
weiß ich gar nicht wie viel, die hatte 32 Gigramm
oder sowas.
Battlefield 6, genau.
PX Forwarding, Battlefield 6.
Ne.
Das Problem war,
SQL selbst
nicht, aber fast, aber fast.
Du bist gar nicht
mit SQL
selbst gar nicht so weit davon
entfernt, was es gewesen ist.
Ihr könnt da nicht drauf kommen, es sei denn ihr habt zufälligerweise gelesen auf Twitter,
dass ich geposte habe, sorry Leute, natürlich auf xformallyknownstwitter,
da lag ein 12 Terabyte SQL Dump auf irgendeinem Laufwerk rum und ein Datenbankadmin hat den mit
Wim geöffnet.
Das hat die Kiste natürlich nicht so gut verkraftet.
Ich hab da geguckt hier.
Links da. Blub. Guck mal, was da offen.
Wim. Hab ich irgendwie gesehen.
Was ist denn das?
Ah ne, jetzt geht's wieder.
So gedacht. Irgendwie meine Tastatur
würde lenken.
12 Terabyte. Ja, der konnte
die 12 Terabyte natürlich nicht öffnen.
Da greifen ja dann auch irgendwelche Limits oder so.
Aber es war schon echt ordentlich.
Machen wir erstmal hier
Updates.
Nochmal Reboot gleich.
Und dann gucken wir uns mal an.
What's new in .NET 10?
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, die ich ausprobieren will.
Das, also
das, was ich am
Wie soll ich das jetzt sagen?
Wo ich mich am meisten drauf freue, ist
die neue extension method geschichte habe ich bisher auch nur im video gesehen mal ausprobieren
32 gigabyte hat ich glaube 32 gigabyte hatte die kiste an ram
aber die ist total unauffällig normalerweise da
passiert nie was drauf die wusste gar nicht dass sie da ist
Chat, Chat, haben wir Fisi-Azubis gerade da? Ich weiß, ab und zu haben wir mal welche am Start.
Any Fisi-Azubis, die zufälligerweise, das ist jetzt die zweite Frage, die zufälligerweise auch nächste Woche Abschlussprüfung haben?
Also unsere hat nächste Woche Abschlussprüfung.
Da tröge ich ihm die Daumen.
Aber das kriegt er hin.
Ich habe mit
einem Azubi, habe ich die
warte mal,
IHK Prüfung Winter
2024 gemacht.
Wie sie?
Weiß gar nicht, ob es die
online irgendwo, man darf,
man darf die ja eh nicht
irgendwie runterladen oder so.
Aber
vielleicht gibt es ja zufälligerweise
irgendwelche Bilder
davon.
Oder auch nicht.
Zumindest habe ich mit meinem Azubi
die Prüfung gemacht.
GA2
haben wir glaube ich gemacht.
Winter 2014.
Ist auch egal.
Ich habe mir mal zu wie die Abschlussprüfung gemacht.
Und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass sogar in der offiziellen...
Wobei, sagen wir mal so, offizielle Lösungen gibt die IHK ja gar nicht raus.
Aber die gibt so ein Lösungsblatt dabei.
Was wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich gedacht ist für Leute, die korrigieren.
Und da waren mindestens, haben wir gefunden, zwei Fehler in der offiziellen Lösung schon.
Mir fällt nur noch eine ein,
da war eine Programmieraufgabe
und da war der Array-Index falsch.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht,
was in der Lösung drin stand.
Da denke ich mir auch,
wie unfähig kann man sein?
Ihr habt eine Aufgabe, zweimal im Jahr,
oder okay, ihr habt zwei Aufgaben,
zweimal im Jahr so eine Prüfung veranstalten.
Kann man da nicht irgendwie drauf
sich verlassen, also sollte man
sich da nicht drauf verlassen dürfen,
dass das Zeug
fehlerfrei ist und
verständlich.
Und das nächste ist, was mich bei der Prüfung
aufregt, dass die alten Prüfungen
ja gar nicht öffentlich sind. Ich weiß,
dass das schon immer so ist, aber das ist ja nicht
gut, dass das immer so ist.
Das ist schon immer Schrott. Ich weiß.
Aber was ich
auch richtig blöde finde,
ist, dass die Dinger überhaupt nicht öffentlich
sind. Du kannst dir die alten Prüfungen
offiziell nicht angucken.
Ich bin der Meinung,
die alten Prüfungen und die alten Ergebnisse
müssten veröffentlicht werden von der IHK.
Einfach, dass du dich ordentlich vorbereiten kannst
und dass du im Zweifelsfall auch mal sehen kannst.
Guck mal, da gab es ja Fehler oder sowas.
Aber die sind so krass unfähig, Alter.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Was macht eigentlich hier gerade mein Package Manager?
Wenn ich mal fragen darf.
Ey, Package Manager, was passiert da gerade?
Ähm, man bekommt die Dinger ja auch aus, sagen wir mal, semi-frei zugänglichen Quellen, die Abschlussprüfung.
Aber ich bin halt der Meinung, das sollte man auch so öffentlich bekommen bei der IHK und nicht über irgendwelche Verlage oder irgendwelche Rapid-Share-Links.
Kennt das überhaupt noch jemand?
Keiner kennt mehr Rapid Share
Also die ganzen Zoomer kennen auf jeden Fall keinen Rapid Share mehr
Oder sind ja nicht mehr Zoomer
Ist ja Generation Alpha mittlerweile
Da kennt niemand mehr Rapid Share
Kennt ihr noch Rapid Share?
Chat, wer kennt noch Rapid Share?
Ja toll, ne?
Ja, das ist genauso wie mit dem Fachinformatikerbuch.
Meine Güte, Package-Man hat doch was los.
Das ist genauso wie dieses Fachinformatikerbuch, was es früher gab.
Wo nur Leute...
Äh, Schwachsinn.
Wo nur ein Verlag die Rechte hat für dieses Fachinformatikerbuch, was in der Prüfung zugelassen war.
Das war auch so die Lizenz zum Geldrücken.
Du kennst es nicht?
Nee, mit 23 bist du zu jung für RapidShare.
RapidShare war damals einer der ersten
so File-Hoster, wo du Sachen hochladen
konntest und einen Link sharen
und die Leute konnten sie über den Link runterladen.
RapidShare
hat damals, dadurch, dass
sie eines der ersten waren,
die hauptsächliche
Anwaltblut
der Content-Inhaber abbekommen.
Bis sie irgendwann
weg waren.
Und dann, der Mega-Upload
Einfach später.
Mega.
Sekunde.
Mega Upload Song.
Das hat 15 Millionen Views,
der Mega Upload Song.
Krass.
Okay, das ist kaputt.
Leute, es gibt keinen Mega Upload Song.
sagt man macht mein package manager noch was okay das macht was ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher was es macht ehrlich gesagt weil ich hätte jetzt nicht gedacht dass
dass so ein Icon Theme
drei Stunden braucht,
um es zu updaten.
Ich habe die IHK Prüfung auch.
Ich würde die so gerne im Stream mit euch einfach durchgehen,
aber darf man halt nicht.
Das wäre glaube ich echt
Richtig nicer Content
Wir würden einfach
Keine Ahnung einmal im halben Jahr
Oder einmal im Jahr würden wir die Abschlussprüfung
Vor letztem Jahr machen und es ein bisschen lustig machen
Über die IHK
Das wäre Top Content
Übrigens, ich habe jetzt was gelernt
Bezüglich Zuma und Gen Alpha
Sprache
Früher hätte man gesagt
Das wäre Peak Content
Aber
ich hab gelernt, Peak
bedeutet mittlerweile nicht mehr
Spitze oder das ist gut, sondern Peak
wird verwendet für was, was schlecht ist.
Kann das jemand bestätigen?
Oder irgendjemand erklären, wie man
auf so eine Idee kommt?
Also Peak ist jetzt nicht mehr gut,
sondern Peak ist jetzt schlecht.
Wie alt ich bin? 41.
Jaja.
Seht ihr mal.
Ihr habt auch keine Ahnung, ne?
Ihr habt auch keine Ahnung.
Peak bedeutet schlecht, bedeutet nicht mehr gut.
Guck, wir googeln mal danach.
What does peak...
Okay, was meint peak?
Gut oder schlecht?
Wir fragen Chat-GPT mal.
Mal gucken, was Chat-GPT sagt.
Wenn ein Gen-Alpha-Dude
sagt
Peak. Meint er dann
gut oder schlecht?
Ich glaube,
ChatGPT erzählt Mist.
Selten in bestimmten Memes kann Peak
ironisch gemeint so schlecht, dass es
Ja, aber ich weiß, dass
es früher für gut stand, aber mittlerweile
steht Peak für schlecht.
Guck mal, besonders im britischen Slang, wo Peak ironisch so viel wie am schlimmsten bedeutet.
Okay, guck mal, hier gibt es sogar...
Peak kann entweder am besten oder am schlimmsten bedeuten.
Naja
Aber ich
Schon eine ganze Weile nichts mehr gehört
Aber wisst ihr was auch so
Ein Gen-Alpha-Meme ist
Wo ich komplett lost bin
Also ich mein ich bin ja jetzt nicht ganz unbewandt
Was irgendwelche Internet-Memes und Online-Schwachsinn angeht
Also da würde ich sagen
kenne ich mich potenziell
deutlich besser aus,
als der 0815-Jährige,
äh, als der 0815-41-Jährige.
Aber, was ich überhaupt nicht checke,
was daran lustig ist,
ist 6-7.
Genau.
Du wusstest, was ich das jetzt sagen will, oder?
Was ich überhaupt nicht checke,
was, ich mein,
man muss schon sagen, 69 war jetzt nicht
sonderlich lustig, ja?
420 ist auch irgendwie nicht sonderlich lustig.
Das kann ich aber noch alles irgendwie nachvollziehen.
Aber 6-7 check ich nicht mehr.
Da bin ich zu alt für.
Das ist vorbei.
Das Einzige, was ich rausbekommen habe darüber,
aber ich verstehe den Witz da dran,
verstehe ich immer noch nicht,
dass das wohl aus irgendeinem Lied
von irgendeinem Rapper sein muss
und dann damit haben
irgendwelche Leute angefangen,
Baseball-Memes oder so zu machen.
So, und deswegen
jetzt 6-7.
Kein blassen Schimmer, Alter.
Das check ich nicht.
Übrigens, von der Logik her müsste dann auch eigentlich 6'8 kommen, oder?
6'9 hatten wir schon, 6'7 haben wir jetzt.
Was ist denn eigentlich mit 6'8?
Basketball, nicht Baseball. Ja, hast recht.
Du bist mit 25 auch zu alt.
Das ist krasser Generation-Alpha-Slang.
Das sind Leute, die sitzen dann im Zug und sagen, Digger, 6-7 Handy-Akku oder sowas.
Und dann pissen sie sich weg.
Wobei sagt man Digger überhaupt noch?
Wahrscheinlich ist das auch Bräh.
Wahrscheinlich ist das auch komplett out.
Digger sagt wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr.
Also, das hat man bei mir schon noch nicht gesagt
Das ist auf jeden Fall neuer
Bei mir war Alter voll angesagt
Da hat man immer gesagt, Alter
So, sind jetzt die Updates mal durch
Ne
Also, es gibt
Für mich ist Berliner Deutsch
Das schlimmste Dialekt, den es gibt
Gibt ja Leute, die sagen, Sächsisch ist das schlimmste Dialekt
Finde ich gar nicht
Ich finde Sächsisch überhaupt nicht schlimm
Berliner Deutsch
Das ist
Das cringet von mir alles, wenn ich das höre
Kannst mal kicken
Und so Zeug
Schlimm, ganz schlimm
Warum ist das jetzt abgekackt?
Ach ne, Packet Tracer ist abgekackt
Denn das interessiert mich ja nicht.
Okay, wir haben geupdatet.
Jetzt updaten wir noch die ganze Jetbrains-Geschichte.
Wir brauchen eine neue Rider-Version.
Und dann können wir tatsächlich anfangen, uns .NET 10 anzugucken.
Schweizer ist top.
Schweizer.
Was ich auch nicht so mag, ist so Wiener Dialekt.
Das klingt immer so knatschig.
Aber das geht alles.
Das geht alles. Nur Berliner.
Nur Berliner. So diesen Berliner Dialekt.
Den mag ich überhaupt nicht.
Das heißt nicht, dass ich zwangsläufig die Leute nicht mag.
Aber den Dialekt mag ich nicht.
Wobei, seriously, die meisten Leute aus Berlin sind auch übelst lost, ey.
Ich hab letztens ein Video geguckt, Alter.
Berlin, ey.
Ich hab letztens ein Spiegel-TV-Video geguckt.
von irgendeinem komischen Hotel in Berlin, wo die ganzen Assis irgendwie drin wohnen und das Arbeitsamt bescheißen.
Und da haben die ein paar Leute interviewt und ich hab mir schon gedacht, Alter, das ist ja schlimmer als Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof, ne?
Und danach haben sie den Bürgermeister, den Berliner Bürgermeister interviewt und er hat sinngemäß gesagt,
ach, lasst uns doch mal alle zusammen ein Fest feiern, da wird das schon wieder gut.
Ja, ganz bestimmt
Die ganzen Asis haben sicherlich nur drauf gewartet
Dass man da
Sich alle an den Händen hält und ein Fest zusammen feiert
Und dann sind die alle ganz lieb
Und alle mögen sich wieder
Da hab ich mir gedacht, meine Güte
Wie weltfremd kann man da eigentlich sein
So, Updates sind durch
Reboot
Ich weiß nicht von welcher Partei
Ich glaube von den Grünen ist der
Der Berliner Bürgermeister
Der Beitrag war wirklich
Es war schon echt
Schwierig anzugucken
Der Iron Champ ist am Start.
Wobei die Engländer, die Engländer sagen ja Iron Champ.
Die sagen nicht, das Rrrr wird ja nicht ausgesprochen.
Die sagen ja auch nicht Iron Maiden.
Dann war das nicht der.
Dann war das nicht der Berliner.
Ich habe gerade nachgeguckt, das war der nicht.
Das ist nicht der.
aus dem Video.
War das vielleicht der Bürgermeister von dem Stadtteil
oder sowas?
Da muss der das auch von
dem Stadtteil gewesen sein.
Also,
ey, jetzt ist das wieder...
Also ich meinte diesen beiden hier.
Spiegel, TV,
YouTube Berlin
Hotel. Irgendwie so ist das.
Das da, genau.
Das gucken wir jetzt nicht, Leute. Das ist...
Da ist man schlecht drauf,
nachdem man das geguckt hat.
So, hier, der ist doch der Bürgermeister.
Den da, den da meine ich. Den Typ.
So. Das ist der
Jörn Oldmann.
Ach, der Bezirksbürgermeister ist das.
Kennt noch jemand die Uyaku?
Klar kenne ich die noch.
Die hatte mal für eine Woche Hype
und danach ist sie in die Versenkung verschwunden
und keiner hat sich jemals wieder näher angeguckt.
So, wir haben rebooted.
Oh Leute, ich habe übrigens Bauchschmerzen, Alter.
Dabei habe ich heute überhaupt nichts Schlimmes gegessen zum Mittag.
Ich hab Nudel
Ich hab Nudel gegessen mit Hähnchen
Und so ein bisschen Currysoße dabei
Überhaupt nichts wildes
Keine Ahnung
Kann sein, dass ich demnächst hier
Pepo Pupu machen muss
Wo haben wir eigentlich
Haben wir das Emote eigentlich noch
Wo ist das
Wo haben wir das Pepo Pupu Emote
Das gab es doch irgendwo.
Da.
Das ist übrigens ein bisschen kaputt in WPF.
Der ist hier irgendwie auf Speed beim Kacken.
So, wir machen jetzt mal alles zu.
Left.
Zack.
So, Rider.
Wobei, habe ich jetzt hier das Zeug geupdatet?
Nice.
Gut, dann können wir anfangen.
Also, .NET 10.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Bevor wir anfangen, habe ich .NET 10 überhaupt schon installiert?
Ich glaube, ich habe noch irgendeine Preview installiert.
Oder ist mein System .NET sogar schon auf 10 jetzt?
Alter, wenn man mal richtig tippen könnte, ne?
Ey!
Meine Tastatur laggt!
Neun ist es noch.
Meine Tastatur! Ey, die...
Ohne Scheiß, die laggt, wirklich?
Das muss einer... Ey, die laggt!
Was ist das?
Ich drück grad hier nach oben
und direkt die linke Maustaste...
Die linke Pfeiltaste und manchmal...
manchmal lags manchmal nicht jetzt wieder das liegt an der windows 10 an der
windows 11 virtualisierung ich muss jetzt ich habe jetzt hier ich habe ja
vor allem bei workstation laufen aber meine vm die läuft jetzt mit die läuft
jetzt irgendwie über hyper wie unter der unter der haube weil es sonst nicht mal
anders funktioniert richtig für nase habe ich euch
Reject.
Schaust du dir heute Aspire...
Nee.
Aspire ist so ein Ding,
ich gette überhaupt nicht
den Hype, den Microsoft da drum generieren
will.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen,
wo ich nicht checke,
was manche Leute dran so tolle finden.
Das ist, zuerst ist Aspire,
das nächste ist Blazer
und das nächste ist Maui.
Also jetzt mal aus dem .NET Umfeld. Wobei .NET
aspire ist ja gar nicht mehr dort netz bei es ist ja nur noch aspire und auf
der dort net conf da habe ich auch ein paar sachen geguckt der erste tag
bestand zu ungefähr 50 prozent aus ai ai ai ai ai ai und zwischendurch gab es
mal so was new in c sharp 14
Welche Version von VMA benutzt du denn die neueste?
Ich habe geupgradet.
Ich habe geupgradet auf 25.
Das ist die neue kostenlose, die jetzt nichts mehr kostet.
Die jetzt quasi free gemacht wurde.
Oh.
So, lass mal Rider starten.
Also, Laser mag ich überhaupt nicht.
Dafür muss ich...
Also, eins muss man Microsoft ja wirklich mal lassen.
Was sie die letzten Jahre über enorm gut hinkriegen,
ist dieses Umstellen,
dass immer mehr Ahead-of-Time-Compilation unterstützt wird.
Das ist sehr nice.
Bisschen blöd ist,
dass sie, glaube ich, mittlerweile...
Oh, ich weiß es aus dem Kopf gar nicht,
was die Mindest-Gelib-C-Version unter Linux ist.
Also du brauchst eine halbwegs neue Distribution,
dass dein IoT-Binaries, dass die laufen.
Aber es geht.
Also Linux der letzten fünf Jahre läuft alles.
Können wir Rider schon mal starten.
Und ansonsten muss ich sagen,
die Language-Designer, finde ich,
machen echt einen guten Job bei Microsoft.
Man kann sich ein bisschen drüber streiten, ja, manche Sachen hat man so den Eindruck, ey, das bauen die nur ein, weil irgendwie bei Microsoft selbst mal einer gesagt hat, irgendwelche Windows Interop Sachen sind kacke, da brauchen wir was für und dann machen die das.
Ein paar andere Sachen sind vielleicht ein bisschen, ein bisschen zu viel des Guten, ja.
Also ich hätte beispielsweise, meiner Meinung nach, ich hätte diese Primary Constructor Geschichte nicht gebraucht.
Und es gibt noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen muss man echt sagen, macht Microsoft wirklich, also was C Sharp angeht, einen super Job.
Und was .NET angeht auch.
Es ist etwas schade, dass die Benahmung lange Zeit so doof war.
Und dass viele Leute heute immer noch denken,
.NET ist eine Windows-Only-Sache.
Was ja schon die letzten...
Boah, frag mich nicht.
Zehn Jahre? Oder wie lange gibt es .NET Core?
Gibt es auf jeden Fall schon eine ganze Weile.
Zehn Jahre...
gar nicht mehr der Fall ist.
Ich meine, ihr seht es hier im Stream.
Wir haben es schon öfters was in .NET gemacht.
Ich mache das nur unter Linux.
und das geht einfach.
Ist .NET noch ein großes Ding?
Das ist eines der größten, die es gibt.
Also wenn man sich mal anguckt,
wie das Ganze so in Umfragen
wegkommt und auf GitHub wegkommt,
ich würde mal sagen, so Top 5
ist das immer noch
und meiner Meinung nach ist es auch
eher mehr geworden die letzten Jahre.
Also .NET Core, der Ansatz, wie es
Microsoft da gefahren hat, das nochmal
neu aufzulegen und zwar cross platform war auf jeden fall der richtige maui ist für guis
Also du machst sicherlich nichts falsch, wenn du dir heute .net anguckst, beziehungsweise
... beziehungsweise sich ablernst.
Das ist nicht verkehrt.
.NET hat ein ganz gutes Ökosystem.
.NET hat vor allem ein großes Unternehmen dahinter, das ist morgen auf jeden Fall nicht weg.
Microsoft setzt ja da auch selbst drauf.
und je nach
Business, Enterprise
Unternehmen, wo du bist,
ist .NET entweder ein großes Ding
oder eher Java, aber
die Chancen stehen zumindest nicht schlecht, da auch was
zu finden in .NET.
Du magst Microsoft. Ich mag
Microsoft auch nicht. Ich bin
wirklich kein großer Microsoft-Fan,
geschweige denn Windows-Fan.
Aber .NET ist nice. C Sharp mag
ich microsoft mag ich nicht aber sie schafft ist also wenn du mich fragst ist sie schafft
eines meiner top top lieblings programmier sprachen also meine meine lieblings programmier
sprachen sind auf platz eins geteilt ja platz eins und zwei ist geteilt ich kann mich da nicht
so ganz entscheiden ist ruby und sie schafft ich ich gebe den mal beiden so geschert platz eins und
und 2 ruby ist rein von der von der vom wie man es schreibt und von der syntax
her und wie wie gut das danach aussieht und so ist ruby finde ich die beste
programmiersprache die je erfunden wurde leider nur ist ruby überhaupt nicht mehr
verbreitet
ruby hatte den wahnsinns hype was ruby on rails zu der ruby on rails zeit ruby
on Rails hier? Bei welcher Version
sind die eigentlich gerade?
Acht.
Ich glaube zuletzt habe ich mal reingeguckt,
bei 4.1 oder irgendwie sowas.
Ja, da hatte Ruby eine ziemlich große Verbreitung.
Das Ganze kam irgendwann
2006 oder so.
Warte mal, hier steht es doch.
2004 kam das raus.
da war hatte ruby eine große verbreitung und man darf nicht vergessen also viele viele startups
haben damals auch ruby und rails verwendet twitter war am anfang ruby und rails twitch war am anfang
glaube ich sogar ruby und rails das war ziemlich verbreitet geht's github github geht lab ist es
heute immer noch also vieles war am anfang ruby und rails so was in dieser zeit entstanden ist
und ruby ist auch wirklich eine echt schöne programmier sprache wie example
ob die vielleicht auch gleich was und es kommt mir bitte keiner mit sieht aus wie
michel basic ruby ist es ist super super programmier sprache also wenn ihr mich
fragt die schönste Programmiersprache, die es gibt.
Nach Python? Ne, nicht wirklich.
Ah, Ruby ist sehr nice.
Zumindest
ist Ruby und C Sharp, teilt sich
bei mir meine Top 1
und 2, was Programmiersprachen angeht.
Also,
vom Bauchgefühl her würde ich sagen
eindeutig Ruby, aber Ruby ist halt
überhaupt nicht mehr verbreitet und ich habe lange nichts mehr mit Ruby
gemacht, aus dem Grund.
C Sharp ist eigentlich
so meine Nummer 1, für wenn ich
einfach nur was ausprobieren will
und noch nicht genau weiß, ob das was wird,
ob das eine gute Idee ist, sonst was,
dann bastle ich meistens mal schnell was in C Sharp
zusammen, das geht schnell,
das hat super Tools und die Sprache
an sich ist auch schön.
Das ist eine Sache, die gefällt mir an .NET wirklich gut.
.NET hat eine super Standard-Library, wenn nicht die beste von den verbreiteten Sprachen.
Also, wenn man das mal vergleicht mit, na gut, Rust können wir nicht nehmen, Rust ist nicht in der gleichen Liga und auch von der Standard-Library ein bisschen minimalistisch.
aber wenn es mal mit Go zum Beispiel vergleicht, ja, Go hat eine deutlich minimalistischere Standard-Library.
Go hat zwar auch zum größten Teil alles Wichtige dabei, aber nicht alles.
Dafür muss man sagen, dafür hat Go manche Sachen dabei, die .NET nicht dabei hat, nämlich den CSV-Parser zum Beispiel.
Ich glaube, Go hat in der Standard-Library einen CSV-Parser drin, warum auch immer.
und das braucht aber die standard sei also dort netzstandard sei ist top du
hast mehr oder weniger fast alles was du brauchst schon dabei
manchmal ist es auch ein bisschen zu viel des guten in der netzstandard
library also wie viele timer klassen gibt es in der dort netzstandard
mittlerweile 56 oder so date time handling ist auch nicht gerade geil
aber zumindest die dort netzstandard ist super dazu kommt dass die schar so was
wie link hat was mir in so ziemlich was wir in so ziemlich kann man doch nur in
breiter machen was wir in so ziemlich jeder programmier sprache fehlt die
nichts vergleichbares hat aber wir machen es wir dort erzählen
wo ist denn hier mein dort net gibt's
krass mit dotnet new console muss man ja machen so aber kurz weiter auf
Oh, Ryder hat ein neues Bild.
Aha.
Excellent.
Wir können den Ryder einfach mal so aufmachen.
Zack.
Jaja, wir trusten.
Wir trusten allem.
Eines der besten Sachen in .NET ist eindeutig,
dass sie sowas wie Link zum Beispiel dabei haben.
Üh, was ist denn das?
Wir haben einen neuen Skin von der IDE.
MonkaS.
Chat.
Ähm.
Ich muss mal ganz kurz...
Afk.
Es drückt.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
2-3 Minuten.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So, da bin ich wieder.
Dringende Sache.
Musste erledigt werden, Chat.
Hä?
Kann man das nicht.
Alter, ich will mein Fenster bewegen.
So.
Also.
Ich geh noch mal kurz den Chat durch.
Weil da waren noch ein paar Sachen, wo ich was zu sagen wollte.
Nämlich irgendjemand hat auch gefragt,
was man als Fisi können soll und sowas.
Da wollte ich schon was zu sagen.
Python und Performance gehören nicht in den selben Satz.
Das kann man so ohne weiteres gar nicht sagen.
Python selber ist sicherlich nicht die krasse Performance-Sprache,
aber nachdem die Sachen, die Performance brauchen, in Python oftmals als C-Module implementiert sind,
so NumPy und sowas, ist die Performance dafür auch nicht unbedingt schlecht.
Aber ich würde auf jeden Fall nicht Python nehmen, wenn ich irgendwas bräuchte, wo es auf brutal Performance ankommt.
Das ist schon richtig.
Da wird wahrscheinlich, auch wenn die Rust-Leute jetzt stinkig sind, so rein was Entwicklungsgeschwindigkeit angeht und so Runtime-Performance würde ich sagen, kommt an C und C++ wahrscheinlich nichts vorbei.
Rust ist sicherlich in der ähnlichen Liga was Performance angeht, allerdings Rust ist viel, nennen wir es mal anstrengender zu programmieren.
was was ich also video gestreift was ich an sie schaffe ist dass ich mich mit manch meiner damen
kollegen ich aus weil nichts von javascript haben und ich nichts von sich gut da kann aber jetzt
die schar nix dafür dass du es nicht checkt so geht auch nicht wobei man neigt dazu ich kenne
das auch man neigt manchmal dazu von sachen wo man keine ahnung hat die kacke zu finden
man denkt das taugt nichts manche sachen sind aber dann viel besser als man
eigentlich denkt ich war früher überhaupt kein fan von go ich habe immer
mal ein bisschen benutzt und habe mich immer voll durch gequält und gedacht
braun ist das eklig aber irgendwann hat das mal geklickt bei go und seitdem
finde ich kaum mega nice
Microsoft macht viele geile Sachen.
TypeScript via Code.net.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
TypeScript habe ich nicht so großen Plan von.
Aber via Code.net ist nice.
Auch weniger.
Blazer.
Ja gut, das stimmt wohl.
Windows 11 ist auch geil.
Ich mag Windows 11 nicht.
Aber das ist Geschmackssache.
Ob man eine Firma mag, ist doch egal.
Das Nutzen fallen, was einem taugt.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Vor allem, das ist ein bisschen wie früher bei der ewig langen Diskussion PlayStation vs. Xbox.
Da waren ja die Fanboy-Kriege immer super krass, ja.
Scheiß Wixbox, Gaystation 3 und was auch immer sich da immer an den Kopf geschmissen wurde.
Aber ich habe damals auch schon immer gesagt, Leute, es bringt euch überhaupt gar nichts,
da irgendein Unternehmen oder irgendeine Firma so krass zu fanboyen.
Es ist nicht, dass man irgendjemand mal
einen Fanboy des Jahres Award gewinnt
oder sowas.
Das bringt überhaupt nichts. Das benutzen,
was nice ist und den Rest kann man ignorieren.
Und man muss den auch, finde ich,
also gerade bei
Spielen hat man ja früher immer total dazu
geneigt, den manchen Herstellern
so Vorschusslorbeeren zu geben.
Aber das ist von Blizzard, das ist bestimmt
gut. Hat man ja gesehen, wo das hinführt.
Was war das letzte Gute, was Blizzard rausgehauen hat auf Overwatch?
Eins
Das war, wann war denn das?
2016 oder so?
Das ist schon ein bisschen her
Ja, 2016
Moment
Moment, ich kann mit C-Sharp Serveranwendungen programmieren und auf Linux laufen lassen.
Ja klar.
Warum nicht?
Das funktioniert sogar sehr gut.
Ich würde mal behaupten, dass solche Sachen,
dass die wahrscheinlich heutzutage,
lehne ich mich jetzt einfach mal aus dem Fenster.
Ich kann es nicht belegen.
Keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich so ist.
Ich würde mal behaupten,
ASP.NET Anwendungen laufen heute wahrscheinlich mehr
auf Linux als unter Windows.
Von der Summe her.
Ich hoffe, keiner muss noch irgendwelche IES-Anwendungen betreiben.
Jetzt, wo ich den Namen gerade lese...
Ich weiß nicht, ob du noch da bist.
Ich glaube, ich habe ein PowerShell-Buch von dir.
vor 15 Jahren oder so.
Ich seh's jetzt relativ sicher.
Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Ich glaub, ich hab ein PowerShell-Buch von dir gekauft.
Ähm.
Das hoffe ich auch.
Das wäre nice.
Wenn wir Union-Types bekommen würden
in C-Sharp 15.
Ich kann keine einzige Programmiersprache, sagt der Fabian.
Dann ist jetzt der beste Zeitpunkt, damit anzufangen.
Also meine Top 5 Programmiersprachen, um das mal fertig zu machen,
sind immer noch, wie gesagt, Ruby, C-Sharp, Go, JavaScript
und ihr werdet es mir nicht glauben, aber C++.
C++ ist wahrscheinlich die ekligste und abartigste Programmiersprache, die es gibt.
Also die Programmiersprache, die nicht dafür gemacht ist, eklig und abartig zu sein.
Also ich rede jetzt nicht von sowas wie Brainfuck oder so, das ist ja dafür gedacht, abartig zu sein.
Aber C++ ist die abartigste Programmiersprache, die als normale Programmiersprache gedacht ist.
Aber trotzdem ist sie bei mir Top 5.
JavaScript ist ja schon dabei gewesen.
Wie gesagt, Ruby, C-Sharp, Go, JavaScript, C++.
Und C++ ist bei mir hauptsächlich dabei, weil ich sehr gerne Microcontroller-Zeug bastle.
Und da ist C++ einfach das Mittel der Wahl.
Das ist doch nicht mal Ragebait.
Ich meine das wirklich so.
Ich sage nicht absichtlich was Kontroverses oder so zum Leute-Träger.
Pearl hat Potenzial gehabt.
Ja, 2005 oder so vielleicht.
Was war das hier?
Ja.
Das stimmt wohl.
Moment.
Das da war doch Lock4J, oder?
Oder war das...
Das hier!
Das hier war Log4J, stimmt's?
Das hier war Log4J.
Visual Studio und Visual Studio Code sind nicht schlecht, ne?
Doch, doch, doch, wir haben Leute bei uns im Team, die machen ausschließlich Windows-Kram, die mögen Microsoft voll.
Also die sind da voll im Microsoft-Ökosystem drin und feiern das ab.
Der Red Doctor ist extrem produktiv mit C-Sharp, ich auch.
Deswegen ist das meine Default-Wahl, was Sprache und Umgebung angeht, wenn ich noch nicht genaueres weiß oder mal ein bisschen rumprobieren will.
Irgendjemand hat doch gefragt?
Mit Fisi als Fisi?
Ach hier.
aktuelle anwendungen heutzutage laufen das ist am meisten sind in einem
container auf dem kubernetes cluster oder sowas
da muss ich teilweise auch ein anwendungsentwickler ein bisschen
gedanken drum machen okay wir laufen der kontinuierten umgebung bei uns ist sogar
so die bauen sogar eigene docker falls teilweise und das ist ja was was früher
eher so klassisch in Richtung FISI gelaufen ist.
Oder von Systemintegratoren gemacht wurde.
Also das ist teilweise ein bisschen schwierig zu trennen.
Dann hat sich ja diese ganze DevOps-Geschichte auch etabliert,
dass du wirklich Leute hast, die sich um CICT-Bipelines kümmern,
um Automatisierung, um Infrastructure as Code.
dass nach Möglichkeit
eine Dev-Umgebung einfach gestartet werden kann
und wieder zerstört werden kann und solche Geschichten.
Das hat viel Überlappung
heutzutage.
Also ja, es gibt noch Leute,
die programmieren den ganzen Tag und ja,
es gibt auch noch Leute, die sind den ganzen Tag auf irgendeinem Linux-Terminal,
aber es ist schon
ein bisschen mehr, also die Überschneidung ist deutlich
größer geworden, die letzten
Jahre über. Deswegen bin ich
der Meinung, auch ein Feezy
sollte programmieren können welche sprache ist erst mal gar nicht so
wichtig natürlich wäre es sinnvoll eine sprache zu beherrschen die einem hilft
den arbeitsalltag besser auf die reihe zu kriegen und da gibt es eigentlich nur
zwei sachen unter linux und eigentlich nur eine sache unter linux die man
wirklich können sollte und das ist best programmieren oder best skripten das ist
ziemlich das was dir da am meisten bringt es allerdings ziemlich miese
programmier sprache also wenn du da was umfangreiches drin machen willst ist
nicht unbedingt dass das mittel der wahl ja deswegen würde ich sagen ach so und
der windows ist es wahrscheinlich powershell aber dazu kann ich nichts
sagen deswegen würde ich sagen als wie sie
sollte man mindestens eine shell scripting sprache seiner seines bevorzugten wo es beherrschen also
powershell unter windows oder bash unter linux und dazu noch eine andere programmier sprache
sowas wie zum beispiel go wenn du im cloud umfeld unterwegs bist ganz ganz viele sachen sind dort in
go programmiert ja terraform zum beispiel ist in go programmiert kubernetes selbst ist in go
programmiert also da ein bisschen gut zu können ist nicht verkehrt was auch nicht
verkehrt ist generell für alle die was mit computer zu tun haben javascript
weil so ein bisschen frontend zeug bisschen javascript css html ist nie
verkehrt und so ganz dran vorbei kommt auch keiner
kuba netz ist in go programmiert ja ok github kuba netz ja so zeige ich dir
hier ist command line keine ahnung wo ich da wo ich jetzt hingehen soll
proxy guck da wenn ich das ist ein programmiert er sehr vieles in dem cloud
umfeld ist ganz ganz viel deswegen ist eine super sprache und go finde ich ist
auch für einen fiesi eine gute sprache weil man wird ja bestimmt mal die ein
oder anderen command line tools entwerfen und sofern es über so simple
automatisierung raus geht ist go meiner meinung nach die beste programmier
sprache für kommando zeilen tools oder generell so ich nenne es mal so admin
tools oder admin dinge zum beispiel ja wo ich vielleicht mal beispiel
beispiel machen zum beispiel wir haben bei uns auf der arbeit eine software am
laufen die mit der kann man einen polygon blockchain not betreiben so hier
polygon block wir sind super kassai trägt aber ich habe heute sonst nichts
vor polygon so da gibt es eine software die nennt sich übrigens so das ist die
wo heißt die damit kann man einen polygon blockchain not betreiben
das ding ist diese software ist ziemlich buggy und polygon produziert ungefähr
alle zwei sekunden einen neuen block also die polygon blockchain spuckt die
alle zwei sekunden den neuen block aus das heißt wenn du eine note betreibst
musst du so schnell was man muss du kleiner als zwei sekunden neue blöcke
verarbeiten können damit du nicht hinten dran bist blockchain ist nicht total out
blockchain ist gerade im versicherungs und bankensektor kommt das jetzt gerade
so richtig erst an so und eri gon hat manchmal das ding manchmal ist er super
schnell und macht innerhalb von ein paar millisekunden neuen block und manchmal
ist er einfach lahm und braucht zu lange manchmal macht er auch gar nichts mehr
und hört einfach auf und das muss man irgendwie überwachen das selbst hat nicht sonderlich viele
möglichkeiten sich selbst zu monitoren ja eri gott bleibt auch manchmal einfach hängen und macht gar
nichts es ist nicht etwa so dass es dann crash oder sowas nee das bleibt einfach hängen macht
gar nichts oder sehr langsam was das heißt das muss man irgendwie monitoren so was ich jetzt
jetzt gemacht habe ist auf der arbeit ich habe in go ein prometheus exporter
programmiert und das den nebel erigon im kuban ist das kloster als zeit k laufen
und das sind solche admin dinger die ich meine dafür ist go einfach die beste
sprache die es gibt keine andere programmier sprache change my mind
leute keine andere programmier sprache ist so gut geeignet für self content
binaries die überall laufen und sich dementsprechend super easy
containerisieren lassen wie go sagt mir irgendeine sprache die ähnlich wo es
ähnlich gut funktioniert wie bei go
das heißt die kombination aus shell scripting sprache des betriebssystems
was du verwendest plus go ist auf jeden fall nicht verkehrt für ein fisi sie
schafft zu lernen ist auch nicht verkehrt und javascript aber ich finde
eine gute Mischung ist tatsächlich Bash
und Go.
Ja.
Vibecone ist ja schön und gut,
du musst aber auch checken, was passiert.
Oder einfach hoffen.
Es macht alles so, wie du willst.
Ihr benutzt so gut für Windows,
ja dann ist es bei dir powershell powershell und sicher sie schafft ist gerade was windows
angeht auch nicht verkehrt das kommt ja aus der richtung also vielleicht ist für dich eine gute
kombination powershell powershell läuft ja auch auf dotnet basis powershell und sie schafft ist
für dich wahrscheinlich gar nicht verkehrt als wie sie es auf jeden fall gut zu können übrigens
auch als windows admin doch er ist auch in go genau ja chat ihr wisst was das hier ist oder
ihr wisst was passiert wenn man das unter linux eintippt oder gut bei mir passiert nichts weil
meine limits klein genug sind das ist eine forkbomb jetzt kommt der große preis jetzt
kommt die große preisfrage wer von euch traut sich zu zu erklären gibt es ein sap für gibt
es ein sap für wer von euch kann erklären was es macht und vor allem warum das system frist
wenn man es ausführt weil das system frist kann ich glaube ich habe limits gesetzt mein system
würde glaube ich nicht fließen probieren wir auswahl man snapshot nach läuft
mal
also sagt hier wer guckt
Nee, guck mal, mein System kackt auch.
Leute, guck mal, eine Load von 800, Alter.
Eine Load von 2000.
F.
Hast du auch nicht genug Limits gesetzt anscheinend.
Eine Load von 4000.
Okay, jetzt ist gefreest jetzt vorbei.
Gut.
Deswegen habe ich einen Stepshot gemacht
Ja, also, okay
Ich versuche es mal zu erklären
Wir brechen mal die Syntax
Ein bisschen runter
Okay
So
Ja, ja, aber
Ich wollte jetzt eher drauf raus
was die Teile davon sind und warum das in Bash gerade so gut funktioniert.
Ich erzähl's einfach mal.
Also, das hier ist ein Name.
Das hier ist eine Funktionsdefinition.
Das heißt, wir legen eine Funktion an, die Doppelpunkt heißt.
Hier.
Das ist eine Funktion, die den Namen bekommt, Doppelpunkt.
Das hier sind einfach Klammern.
Hier.
Start.
Ende
von der Funktion.
Und das hier
ruft die Funktion
sich selbst auf,
pipet es
nach sich selbst und schickt
es in den Hintergrund. Also hier passiert
die Magic eigentlich.
Und dadurch, dass es hier in den Hintergrund
geschickt wird,
blockt es an der Stelle auch nicht.
Und startet ganz viel
neu.
Ja, und das letzte Doppelpunkt
ist dafür,
es einmal initial in Gang
zu setzen. Also das hier ist eine
Funktion, die ruft sich die ganze Zeit selbst auf.
Ruft sich selbst auf,
pipet es nach sich selbst und schickt es in den Hintergrund.
Und das hier braucht man, also wenn ich
das hier, guck mal so,
wenn ich das hier nehme,
Nehmen wir nochmal die Forkbomb
Wenn ich das letzte
Wenn ich nur das hier nehme
Wenn ich nur das hier nehme, passiert nichts
Sobald ich jetzt aber
Doppelpunkt ausführe
Oh, oder auch doch
Äh, okay
Warum?
Chat, warum?
Warum ist das jetzt losgegangen?
aber ich habe ausgeführt habe hier oben oder weil ich hinter gedrückt habe ich
kaklul
aber snapshot wird da jetzt sind wir super kass seit direkt worden aber so
ist es halt ist power power stelle ist nicht die schar power stelle ist dort
an der hut sondern sind wir das will das ja eigentlich die von mir die ganze zeit
gut so dann können wir mit dort nicht anfangen würde ich sagen ich werde
mir noch mal ganz schnell kurz was zu trinken holen ich habe trockenen hals
Also auf geht's.
Was ist neu in .NET 10?
Was sagst du?
Habe ich nur ganz kurz gelesen, dass Proxmox jetzt auch Docker Images oder normale Container Images, OCI Container Images kann.
Soweit ich das gelesen habe, ist es allerdings so, dass sie nicht direkt OCI-Images unterstützen, sondern OCI-Images aus einer Registry runterladen und dann quasi Container in Container machen.
Also sie starten einen LXC-Container, wo dann selbst drin wiederum, keine Ahnung, irgendwas anderes läuft, was dann das OCI-Image startet.
So habe ich das gelesen, also das war nicht so geil.
also es war jetzt irgendwie so ein bisschen
but why? das habe ich mich auch gefragt
genau das habe ich mich auch gefragt
ich weiß nicht warum
übrigens Leute, das beste Feature
in C Sharp seit Jahren schon
und eines der besten Sachen
ist das, was ich vorher eigentlich kurz zeigen wollte
was ich in jeder anderen
Programmiersprache
Das stimmt nicht. Das Image wird einfach in einer LXC-Konvertierten
direkt ausgeführt.
Ach so ist das.
Okay, ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht?
Das heißt aber auch, du kannst nicht einfach updaten, oder?
Kannst du dann einfach updaten?
und sagen so hier, keine Ahnung,
Config-Verzeichnis behalten und updaten.
Ne, aber das probieren wir heute aus.
.NET Run
Program CS.
Das probieren wir aus.
Ja, Chat, eines der besten C-Sharp-Features
überhaupt, schon seit
10 Jahren plus oder wie lang es das gibt.
Was ich in jeder Programmiersprache vermisse,
die es nicht hat oder sowas ähnliches hat, ist
Link. Vermisse ich in Go übrigens auch.
in C Sharp kann man nämlich ganz einfach
Collections filtern
und umformatieren, ja wenn man zum Beispiel
hier mal sagen, ich nehme jetzt einfach mal
das S-Best was mir einfällt
Processes, ne oh fuck
wie ging das nochmal
war das nicht Processes
System
doch Process
ach Process
Process
so
Das ging doch so, siehst du mal
Wie relativ ist die?
Get Processes
Get Processes, genau
So, jetzt haben wir einen
Bekommen wir einen Array von allen laufenden Prozessen
Sind Collections Bibliotheken
Ne, Collections
Sind sowas wie
eine Liste oder ein Array
oder ein Dictionary
oder eine Hashtable.
Dynamische Arrays?
Wie könnte man,
was ist eine Collection?
Eine Datenstruktur, wo du
eine
variable Anzahl von
Elementen drinne
speichern kannst.
das glaube ich ganz gut wenn wir jetzt sagt hier geht mir alle prozesse die gerade laufen
unter linux führen das mal aus der hier war prozesses gleich da war jetzt hier eine schleife
drüber for each moment da was haben sie die ei sinnvolles vorgeschlagen ja das ist gut so
prozessor das gehen wir das einfach aus process name sagt wenn ich das jetzt starte
dann kommt jetzt ganz viele prozesse hier also im prinzip das gleiche was damit h top oder oder
oder ps oder so auch oder ps hier auch sieht gibt ganz viele gibt ganz viele prozesse so und
jetzt kommt es ja manchmal vor da ich sage ich will ich will eigentlich nur die prozesse haben
die mit
keine Ahnung, die mit
die mit DNS anfangen, okay?
Ich will nur alle Prozesse filtern, die mit
DNS anfangen.
Da würde man jetzt in Go
zum Beispiel, in Go
gibt es ja nicht sowas wie Link oder irgendwelche
anderen Filtergeschichten.
in Go würde man jetzt eine Schleife machen.
Würde dann sagen,
if
process
äh, ja, name
start
mit DNS
zum Beispiel. So, und dann weiter.
Und wenn ich dann zählen will,
wie viele das sind, bräuchte ich dann hier oben
noch so eine Counter-Variable
und würde dann hier quasi sagen, count++
und am Ende gebe ich das aus. Also so würde man das
dann in Go machen, natürlich in Go-Syntax.
In C Sharp geht das Ganze viel besser.
Da kann ich einfach sagen, okay,
Processes
und jetzt
kommt Link ins Spiel.
Kann ich sagen, where
Was zum Teufel schlägt mir
die EI da vor?
Where Process Name
Process Name
starts with DNS
und dann sage ich am ende einfach count sagt ach so ja man kann das was hat er jetzt für schmerzen
ist wieder von mir replace mit der single ja es geht natürlich auch so stimmt und schon so ist
eigentlich richtig nice und schon kriege ich die anzahl aller prozesse die mit dns anfangen und das
Sind zwei.
Das sind auch tatsächlich zwei.
Guck hier.
Und das ist so geil.
Und das vermisse ich in jeder Programmiersprache.
Die sowas nicht hat.
Das ist doch normales MapReduce.
Im Prinzip ist es ja auch sowas.
Aber es gibt halt viele Sprachen, die haben das nicht dabei.
Ja, du hast zum Beispiel in Go nichts dergleichen in der Standard Library.
Und schon gar nicht, und schon gar nicht als Methode auf beispielsweise der Listen, List-Implementierung.
Du kannst es natürlich noch beliebig weiter chainen, ne.
Das ist ja das Gute, also das war jetzt hier nur ein ganz, ganz kurzer Ding.
Du könntest auch sagen, hier, where process name gleich DNS und dann sagst du select und davon wollen wir jetzt quasi, wir wollen eine neue Variable haben, nur mit exit code und dann davon das erste.
oder davon jetzt also man kann das dann so schön miteinander verbinden und davon
jetzt allerdings nur exit codes die größer null sind zum beispiel also nur
die sachen wo nicht erfolgreich waren oder nur sachen die die null sind so und
das kann man dann kaufen
Man kann das so chainen.
Das ist halt richtig nice.
Link hat so eine eklige Syntax.
Du meinst diese SQL-like Syntax.
Ja, die verwendet aber so gut wie keiner mehr.
Ja, also man kann,
das Rider kann das ja auch umdingsen irgendwie.
Ich weiß bloß gerade nicht,
ehrlich gesagt.
Also Ryder konnte das zumindest
mal relativ sicher.
Konnte Ryder den Kram nicht mal
von
dieser Syntax in die andere Syntax
umschreiben? Also,
es gibt noch diese alte SQL-like
Syntax.
Da konnte man dann sowas machen hier, keine Ahnung,
Count 2, dann sagt man hier,
wie war das, from
process in processes,
würdest du dann sagen.
Where
prozess name gleich dns select process exit code und dann kannst du aber die dann kannst du aber
das nicht mehr hinten dran schäden und so dann müsstest du dann in den sub query machen kann
ehrlich diese syntax verwendet eigentlich so gut wie niemand das ist richtig das ist richtig aber
Das hier, das ist the way to go.
Das kann Collections...
Ja, du kannst sagen, from Processes in Process,
from Blub in irgendeiner anderen Collection, ja.
Und dann könntest du hier das quasi,
dann so Sachen checken wie,
wenn Blub gleich gleich Process ist und sowas.
Ja, das geht mit dieser Syntax hier oben nicht, aber das hat man so selten.
Ja.
Man muss es aber ja auch nicht übertreiben, ne?
Also, nur weil man eine Sache als Linkquery schreiben kann, ist es nicht unbedingt immer das allerbeste und sinnvollste, das in einem Linkquery zu schreiben.
Also wenn man jetzt irgendwie
einen Linkquery hat, was dann irgendwie so
keine Ahnung, so lang ist,
dann vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt das Beste.
Aber für so kleine Sachen
ist das einfach top.
Und ich vermisse das in jeder Sprache, der nicht
sowas ähnliches hat.
So, jetzt aber .NET 10 endlich.
Ich hab keine Ahnung,
ob es da gute Tools gibt.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie in der IHK Abschlussprüfung, oder?
So, zack, .NET 10.
What's new in .NET 10?
Dann gucken wir uns das Ganze doch mal an.
Also ein bisschen habe ich mich im Vorfeld schon informiert, was es gibt.
Aber nur so an der Oberfläche.
Also, what's new in runtime?
Wir scrollen jetzt erstmal kurz drüber, was wir denn hier so Spannendes haben.
Das juckt mich nicht.
Haben die nicht... Ach, hier oben gibt es eine...
Compiler Improvements, neue Instruktionen, Stack Allocation, Native AOT, Pre-Initializer Improvements, was auch immer.
Ich glaube, da ist nichts Spannendes dabei, was wir uns unbedingt angucken müssen.
Native AOT... Nee.
Also nicht so spannend.
.NET Libraries, da kommen jetzt schon eher ein paar Sachen.
Was gibt es Neues?
Kryptostells, DateTime, Strings, Collections, Serialization, System Numerics, Options und Zip-Files.
Windows, WebSocket, WebSocket Enhancement.
Das ist tatsächlich das Einzige, was mich aus der Liste interessiert.
Kann man vielleicht jetzt gescheit WebSockets in ASP.NET Core verwenden ohne Signal A?
das wäre ja mal richtig nice
scrollen wir mal kurz drüber
juckt nicht
juckt mich auch nicht
juckt mich nicht
numerics
validation
aot save
process management
Websockets-Enhancements.
Da können wir mal kurz drüber scrollen.
Stomp.
Oh, erinnert mich an unser Java-Zeug,
was wir gebastelt haben.
Ist aber eigentlich
ein Beispiel. Ich hoffe, die haben vielleicht
ein ASP.NET Core-Beispiel drin.
.NET SDK.
file based apps da bin ich mal gespannt drauf file based apps enhancements man kann jetzt
nämlich angeblich so machen habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert man kann jetzt anstatt im projekt
anzulegen also hier mit cs projekt datei programs die erstmal kann jetzt wohl angeblich das habe ich
nicht getestet probier das mal aus immer nach tmp mk dir lul we ach shit gibt es schon mk dir blub
2000 und jetzt kann man sagen hier war touch programm cs jetzt kann man das wohl irgendwie
direkt ausführen oder so oder auch nicht
anscheinend doch nicht gut da müssen wir das mal lesen wie das funktionieren
soll file based up enhancement file based apps
user local share.net was wie oder nicht wirklich
habe ich nicht
ich habe
ok warum macht man es richtig dann geht es auch genau man kann jetzt man kann
jetzt die schar programme ausführen ohne dass man projektdateien sowas braucht
also es reicht wenn man nur noch eine datei hat programm cs und sie haben ja
vor ein paar versionen eingeführt dass man auch keine main methode man braucht man kann quasi
jetzt direkt starten mit einer leeren datei und direkt loslegen bin ich eigentlich ganz nice
die muss ich mal cs heißen also die kann auch heißen pro krem 67 summa cringe
Kanns nicht.
Die muss anscheinend CS heißen.
Dann geht's.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz nice. Also das ist nett.
Mach Userbin.env.net rein, dann CRMOD plus X.
Das kann ich nicht reinmachen, weil mein .NET ist nicht systemweit.
Ich müsste da wenn schon rein, müsste da wenn schon das da reinschreiben.
Gucken, ob das funktioniert.
So war's da.
Keine Ahnung, ob das funzt.
geht das jetzt
nur so weil weil home verzeichnis
also ich muss home marx
.net
Nee, use das Chat, das funktioniert nicht.
User...
binenf.net
Das ist bei mir
.net 9
Guck das .net 9, das wollen wir ja nicht.
Wir wollen ja .net 10 haben.
Das Funds.
Homemax.net.net.
Da kann man es direkt ausführen.
Okay.
Noch besser.
Und angeblich kann man die Dinger jetzt auch direkt compilen oder so.
Brand doch da.
Genau.
Enhanced.
file based apps.net publish
ja das kennen wir doch schon
ok machen wir mal .net .net publish
programm cs was jetzt passiert es gibt es einen native binary
wie macht er das ohne zu kommt der compiled der ruft einfach dort net im
hintergrund auf das ist cool werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht verwenden geht mir
genauso sagt und die haben auch unser eot gedingstes programm
jetzt ist die große preisfrage
wie rückwärts kompatibel sind diese binaries das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren wir
starten jetzt mal einen Docker-Container.
Das ist nämlich das, wo
Go einfach beste aller
Zeiten ist. Ein Go-Binary
läuft auf jedem Linux
seit Kernel 2.6.32.
Das ist bei .NET nicht der
Fall, aber mal gucken, wie lang,
wie weit rückwärtskompatibel
diese neuen Binaries sind.
Probieren wir das doch mal kurz aus.
Also hier, da ist es.
Docker run.
Haben wir da vielleicht
noch irgendwie ein Ubuntu oder sowas?
ja so wir machen jetzt home max temp
konnte man durfte man so machen bei
ich glaube nicht oder geht das tatsächlich easy
Ach, Pipen nach Donut geht auch.
Okay.
Also, plopp.
Programm. Läuft nicht.
Bam. Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, Leute.
Das ist ein Ubuntu 12.04.
12.04 ist vielleicht
ein bisschen alt, oder?
Oder?
Also ein 13 Jahre
13 und ein halb Jahre altes Ubuntu
Muss nicht sein
Ist glaube ich, ist glaube ich ein bisschen zu viel des Guten
In Go würde das
Übrigens funktionieren, ja
Also in Go, ein aktuelles Go Binary
Könnte ich auf ein Ubuntu 12.04
Schmeißen und es läuft
Machen wir mal Ubuntu
1404.
Auch nicht.
Okay.
Ubuntu 16...
Äh, nein, nein, nein.
Es laggt.
Meine Tastatur laggt. Was ist das?
1604.
Blubb.
Geht immer noch nicht. Okay.
1804.
Auch nicht.
Na, dann wird es aber 2004.
Loop, Program CS.
Immer noch nicht.
Ja, das ist ja Schrott.
Also 2004 wird ja noch benutzt.
Ach so, Globalization ist.
Okay, aber es würde funktionieren.
Es würde funktionieren unter 2204.
Das ist aber nicht.
Das ist aber nix.
Das gefällt mir nicht.
Also 2204 ist ja nur wirklich
nur
nur 4 Jahre.
Ja.
Nein, nicht ganz.
3,5.
Aber als ob Go nicht auch eine
Version von Lib C benutzt. Nein, machen sie nicht.
was hat das gute an go die haben ihre ganzen sachen die sie brauchen selbst implementiert
und das einzige worauf sie sich verlassen dass es ein linux kölner als 26 32 ist
du kannst dein programm so bilden hier cgo enabled gleich null go bild und da kommt ein binary raus
Chat, wenn ihr es mir nicht glaubt,
ich zeige euch das einfach.
Hier ist das
Sonnet-Programm. Da haben wir es ausprobiert.
Wir löschen das jetzt mal wieder.
Und jetzt
machen wir mal hier GoLand auf.
Da drinnen.
Machen wir ein Print. Hello World.
Go machen wir.
Ich habe es doch gelöscht.
Hä?
habe ich das nicht eben gelöscht
ich wollte ich funktioniert gold ich zeige euch das zeige ich das ist das ist
Das ist wirklich fast Magic in Go.
Neues Go Projekt in slash tmp slash blub 2000.
Ist jetzt erstellt.
Zack.
So, und das Einzige, was wir da jetzt reinschreiben, ist FMT...
Oder auch nicht.
Achso, Main.
FMT Print...
Hallo Chat.
So, mehr macht unsere Go-Anwendung nicht.
Die haben wir jetzt hier liegen.
Ich kann es immer wieder beenden.
Zack.
Go, Run, Hello Chat.
So, und jetzt passt auf.
Wir bauen jetzt die Anwendung in Go.
Haben jetzt hier Plup 2000 ist unsere Go-Anwendung.
Hallo Chat.
Jetzt bucht das Ding aus.
Und jetzt machen wir das gleiche nochmal.
Ubuntu 12.04.
Mounten wir einfach mal hier rein.
Plup.
Läuft.
LDD.
Gibt's denn?
Und jetzt noch besser.
Jetzt auf die von .NET.
Die habe ich schon gelöscht.
Oder?
Ja, die habe ich schon gelöscht.
Ähm.
Okay.
Warte mal.
Abends gleich wieder.
Publish.
Da steht auch LibC dann.
guck
und anscheinend halbwegs aktuelle lipc zusätzlich noch
so und jetzt
wir gucken mal
naja gut
container benutzen den hostkernel und mein kernel ist neu genug also
das läuft dann einfach überall
und das ist das geile an go programm
Solange du einen Kernel neuer als 2632 hast, läuft das einfach.
Aber wir waren eigentlich bei .NET, deswegen machen wir mal weiter.
Also das haben wir jetzt ausprobiert.
Eigentlich ein ganz cooles Feature, oder?
Nicht Downloads.
Eigentlich ein ganz cooles Feature.
Aber benutzen werde ich es wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Also es ist schon cool, dass man das so machen kann, aber
Ja
So, boah, ist ja ganz toll
Sorry Leute, Forza ist runtergeladen
Aber sobald die Pendancies drin sind, geht das nicht mehr
Du meinst bei Go, doch, das geht auch
Sobald die Pendancies drin sind
Solange es Go-Dependencies sind
Sobald du die Pendancies zu irgendwelchen
C-Libraries hast, also wenn du jetzt irgendwie
ffm pack go verwendest dann kannst du auch nicht mehr ohne cgo kompilieren
dann hast du wieder dann hast du das gleiche problem
ach so doch das funktioniert auch man kann auch dependencies hinzufügen das
ist auch neu habe ich gelesen in irgendeinem den blog post man kann jetzt
wenn man jetzt sagen wir mal wie mache ich öffne das jetzt hier noch mal in
rider trust und open this window zu also da ist unser dritter rider kann das noch gar nicht
seht ihr das rider checkt es noch gar nicht rider sagt alter was willst du von mir das ist kein
sie schafft projekt aber das geht man kann auch file based apps kann man auch die pendels hinzufügen
sie schafft file based apps die pendels größten vergleich war gleich von den bayeris
Irgendwie ging das
Naja, das kommt dann alles in eine Datei rein
Nougat
Da stand es doch hier
Hier, Package
So ging das
So kann man das jetzt reinschreiben
package system command line ok machen wir mal package
jetzt habe ich ein bisschen ein problem weil rider das nicht weil leider das noch nicht kann
wir kopieren uns das jetzt einfach rüber okay und das war mal weg ich will spektr console
speck speckte console will ich haben 054 also es müsste hier speckte dort console
0.5.4
müsste das eigentlich sein von der von der logik her so und jetzt kann ich hier sagen ans die
console print ne ride oder mark up line in rot hello world ok so zack jetzt bin
ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert also wie ich das gelesen habe müsste das
so klar gehen
PUNZ!
Großer Text.
Das funktioniert.
Also man braucht kein Projekt-File mehr.
Das geht mittlerweile
mit so komischen Annotations hier.
Ein bisschen hagelig irgendwie, ne?
Aber das Funzt.
So, und jetzt vergleichen wir mal
die Binary Sizes
miteinander.
Moment. Publish.
Kann ich mit Packages auch auf lokale
Lips zeigen? Ich glaube schon.
Ich glaube, du kannst es auch so machen.
Habe ich, glaube ich, mal irgendwo gesehen. In irgendeinem Blog.
Post.
So, also. Unser Go-Binary
ist
ist 2,3 MB.
Unser .NET Binary
ist auf jeden Fall ein bisschen größer.
2,5 MB.
Das ist richtig klein geworden.
Soll ich euch das mal sagen?
Früher waren die Dinger 40 MB groß.
Das ist richtig gut.
Mittlerweile.
das dotnet programm ist genauso klein wie das go programm sondern wir können jetzt sogar noch
was setzen wir können sogar noch mal versuchen das noch ein bisschen kleiner zu machen man kann
auch bei publish irgendwie sagen das ist doch ein self content published das ist das aot publish mit
allem
einkompiliert.
Man konnte doch irgendwie
sagen, Compress oder sowas.
Wie geht das? Publish?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Warte mal.
Publish, Strip,
Totnet.
strip wie geht das hier hat man hat war history strip
strip symbols
vielleicht macht er das aber auch standardmäßig schon gucken wir mal ist
auch nicht wirklich kleiner geworden
ab nicht stimmt meine ich das kann auch sein
ist auch nicht kleiner geworden dann sagen jetzt public tippt das kann man
noch machen zippt man könnte das können das tipp
oder compressed hieß das ich glaube kommt compressed muss man das nennen ihr compress
und press
Enable Compression in Single File.
Ja, schön. Und wie
macht man das hier jetzt mit
slash p?
Minus P
Und jetzt einfach so?
Die Syntax ist ja wirklich abartig.
Was ist, wenn ich da was angebe, was es nicht gibt
Dann geht es trotzdem nice, geil
Okay, keine Ahnung, ob das hier
Okay, aber anscheinend habe ich es richtig gemacht
Anscheinend habe ich es richtig gemacht
Also der macht das wohl standardmäßig alles schon
Ja, also
der macht das aber standardmäßig wohl alles schon.
Aber es ist
genauso klein wie das Go-Programm.
Also die 200 KB, die lassen wir jetzt mal außen vor.
Leider läuft das
Programm allerdings nicht so weit
rückwärts kompatibel wie Go.
Ubuntu 22.04
ist, finde ich, ein bisschen
zu neu als kleinster gemeinsamer Nenner.
Muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Also ein bisschen... Also 2004
hätten sie noch unterstützen sollen.
Aber trotzdem nicht schlecht.
Kann man nichts sagen. Das ist schon ganz nice.
Ubuntu 20 ist EOL.
Ja und?
Red Hat 7.
external support läuft bestimmt auch nicht drauf
der fairness halber müssen wir sogar sagen guck mal mein.net programm hat
sogar eine dependency noch drin auf spektr console also wahrscheinlich ist
es dass das so ein minimum.net programm genauso klein wie das go wie das
programm also nicht verkehrt so haben wir das ausprobiert also das ist ein
gutes feature wahrscheinlich werde ich aber nie benutzen
also ich habe da wirklich mir fällt nichts dazu ein wo ich da irgendwie
großartiges anwendungsgebiet für hätte
doch doch vielleicht vielleicht sobald rider das unterstützt wenn man einfach
nur was kleines ausprobieren will eine datei erzeugen und dann öffnen was
reinschreiben und wieder löschen dafür ist vielleicht ganz gut
okay
was gibt es sonst neues nix was was console apps was für ein ding console
apps can nativ wie create container images will ich das überhaupt was
passiert was passiert wenn ich das hier angebe moment
tp publish container
monka ist was passiert und
was jetzt jetzt wurden den container published oder was
docker images
Programm, hier.
Der hat quasi unter der Haube
einen Docker-File gebaut oder sowas.
Und hat dann
das draus... Naja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das
so pock finde. Das ist irgendwie
ein Feature, wo ich mich frage,
but why?
Mit so einem Docker-File hast du trotzdem noch bessere Kontrolle
drüber.
die bauen die image layers direkt okay naja aber was dann am ende rausfällt ist wahrscheinlich
auch nur einen auf was welche welcher basis auch immer den ihr den ihr base image ist
ubuntu oder sowas aber den sinn verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht warum muss das ding
container image bauen können zum zum 3 zeilen docker fall tut doch keinem weh
und dann weiß man auch bescheid das verstehe ich nicht so ganz den sinn
davon es bayern gucken wir uns heute nicht an dort netzkorps gucken wir uns
an was da neues gibt sie schafft 14 gucken wir uns an was es da neues gibt
wischt leute es gibt neuigkeit in wish basic aber es hält sich wohl in grenzen
Ja, aber hier Visual Basic Features.
Maui, gut, das ignorieren wir.
EF Core, ignorieren wir.
Windows Forms.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Visual Basic bekommt mehr neue Features als Windows Forms.
Okay, aber es gibt neue Features für Windows Forms, tatsächlich.
Ich würde sagen 2005, oder?
auf der anderen seite sind wir mal ehrlich ja sehr mal ehrlich wenn du es
formst ist wahrscheinlich immer noch die beste variante wenn du was dort netz
mäßiges für gui haben willst unter windows wenn du also wenn du was
eingebautes haben willst wpf ist bloat und auch outdated es bleibt ja
eigentlich nur avalon ja aber lohn er ist das einzige was irgendwie taugt für
cross-plattformen dort net uno vielleicht jetzt noch das habe ich aber
noch nie ausprobiert windows forms container image erbringen
denen mal nix bringen die man nicht auf blöde ideen
sonst gibt es demnächst windows desktop anwendungen als docker container was
unter der haube allerdings eine hyper wie vm ist dass die machen das auch noch
video 3 gibt es schon gar keine neuen sachen mehr das habe ich schon wieder
vergessen wenn die ui3
wobei das ja auch nichts mit dort net direkt zu tun hat
Jetzt kommen wir mal zu den wichtigen Sachen.
ASP.NET Core.
Und vor allem C Sharp 14.
Das probieren wir jetzt aus.
Also das können wir mal wieder zumachen.
Schieben wir das mal auf den Desktop.
Zack.
Chat, ich bin immer noch so ein bisschen zwiegespalten, was ich von dem neuen Rider-Design halten soll.
Es ist jetzt runder.
Wie findet ihr das?
Mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir, irgendwie hat es mir vorher besser gefallen.
Das ist aber bestimmt Gewöhnungssache.
Du wirst auch runder.
Ich bin die letzten Jahre weniger rund geworden.
Ich denke auch, man gewöhnt sich dran.
Immerhin haben wir hier so halbtransparente
Leisten jetzt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die halbtransparent sind.
Das ist bestimmt nur...
Ah, ne, ne, ne, Leute.
Das ist nur gefaked...
Das ist nur gefakte Transparenz.
Guckt mal.
Das ist nur gefaked.
Da erinnert sich nix.
Fake Transparency.
So gut.
Liquid Ass.
Gut, dann gucken wir uns mal die neuen C-Sharp Features an.
Auf das erste freue ich mich schon seit Jahren, das haben die seit Jahren angekündigt bei Microsoft, nämlich Extension Members.
Soll ich das auch mal ausprobieren?
Ja, Moment
Das benutzt einfach eine andere Libc
Compile das dann auch statisch
Dass das alles mit eingebaut ist
Wollen wir das mal ausprobieren?
Wir können das mal ausprobieren
Das machen wir
Sonst sind wir noch heute da
also dann machen wir jetzt publish minus musik 64
Bäm!
The command
GCC not found.
Was? Ne.
Hast du noch
irgendwo, muss ich noch irgendwas installieren
dafür, dass das funzt?
Oder wir können es ja mal
wir können es ja mal hier ausprobieren.
ECC habe ich doch drauf.
Wir können noch was anderes ausprobieren.
Wir können jetzt hier nach
das Ding hier mal kompilieren.
Ah, da gibt es ein Projekt.
Das checkt er also.
Ah, Moment, das ist jetzt...
Ey, wie geht das jetzt?
Jetzt muss ich ja wirklich AOT...
Moment.
Ich muss jetzt publish AOT.
AOT.
das muss ich angeben.
Machen wir das mal so. Gucken wir mal, ob das
jetzt funzt, was am Ende rauskommt.
Minus C
Release brauchen wir noch, ne?
Bin.
Release.
Dotnet 10.
Warte.
Warum... was ist da so viel Zeug drinne?
War ich das jetzt gerade verkehrt?
Ich will jetzt eigentlich nur gucken, ob das Funs...
Machen wir es mal so.
In Bild liegt das Ding jetzt rum.
Genau, okay.
Jetzt.
Jetzt funzt es.
Okay, gut.
So, und jetzt musste man da was hinten dran machen.
Minus
er muss er das da okay das läuft noch
jetzt
das geht nicht also keine ahnung red doktor wieder das hingekriegt hast aber
bei mir tut tut das nicht weil was ist das hier exit hast du noch irgendwas
spezielles installiert anrechner ist command line option target x64 exzellente
musik ja aber muss man muss hier muss irgendwelche gcc geschichten installieren
Aha
Jetzt geht's bestimmt
Oder auch nicht
Ich lösch das nochmal
Was ist das
Was hat der für Schmerzen
Unrecognized Command Line
Du musst doch
Red Doctor, du musst doch irgendwas gemacht haben
Dass es bei dir funktioniert
bei mir vor
ja dann weiß ich auch nicht
Dann kümmern wir uns...
Wenn du es rauskriegst...
Muss ich da wirklich noch GCC irgendwas Spezielles...
Kernelheader?
Nee, oder?
Das kann es nicht sein.
Also eine Sache.
gucken wir jetzt noch.
Also so einfach ist es anscheinend nicht.
Das ist
Five Hat.
das probieren jetzt nicht aus wenn ich da jetzt bin ich da jetzt rum basteln
ich das rausgekriegt habe das jetzt heute abend noch wartet mal was ist
so okay
aber so mache ich das ja auch
ich habe es genauso genauso wie der dude hier mit dem unterschied dass ich sage
dass ich das ist das bild verzeichnis hatten will
ich muss garantiert irgendwas installieren aber ich habe keine ahnung was
wir fragen mal chat gpt pass auf
das ist eine gute idee das ist eine gute idee dass hier die videos das ist eine gute idee das kann
sein
okay was bild inside alpine linux linux nein will ich nicht install muselkost
compiler
Ah ja, es ist tatsächlich, so wie Tibilius das gesagt hat.
Naja.
Aber das stimmt nicht.
Export
CC
Das juckt den aber nicht
Ne ne das ist dem egal
Was ist das
Aha
Das geht? Das glaube ich nicht.
Das ist halluziniert, Leute.
Das ist halluziniert.
Das glaube ich nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Das ist Halluzination.
Halluzination.
Das ist doch...
Das ist Halluzination, Alter.
Ich denke wieder extra hart.
Die echte Kost ist nicht das, was die meisten ansehen.
wir das jetzt mal kann man nicht vorstellen dass es daran liegt
Chat GPT alter!
Post Champ!
Eieiei, das ist aber...
Gewipe Admin haben wir da.
Aber das Spinery läuft nicht.
die waldes die maut aller an supported relocation type 37 alles klar
mein fahrer macht diesen gcc mal wieder weg
Zum Glück ist es nicht
Type 67
Äh 76
Ne 67 so rum alter
Da werden die ganzen
Gen Alphas jetzt ausgeflippt
Was soll uns das bitte schön sagen
Relocated
Also Leute, so einfach ist es dann doch nicht.
ach guck mal der trotzdem noch die pendels zu lieb c warum also ich weiß
nicht wer es geschrieben hat so einfach ist es anscheinend dann doch nicht so
was einfach self content binary internet zu bauen was so weit zurück falls kompatibel ist wie go hat
bei mir geklappt okay wo hast du es denn kompiliert auf was von linux auf alpine in dem docker container
oder
NixOS.
Ja, da wundert mich nix. Das kann schon sein.
Ich mein,
man könnte es in einem Alpine Linux
schicken.
Das ist eine richtig gute Idee.
Kriegst du es reproduziert in einem
Docker-Container? Da können wir das ja
ausprobieren. Weil sonst hätte ich gesagt,
ich, ähm,
warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal.
curl wartet mal
docker run nach club rm sowie man alpine alpine latest geht das so bei
ich habe schon ewig keine mehr gestartet ist bin sh ok apk ist es da apk update apk install curl
So.
Bash.
Okay.
APK, add, bash.
Bash.
Wir sind ein wenig sidetracked würde ich sagen, aber macht ja nix.
So.
Und jetzt bauen wir das hier nochmal.
Nach Blub.
Blub, da liegt das Bruchzeug rum.
Program CS.
Ich glaube, das hat ein paar Probleme gerade.
also und helferin kriege das nicht zu laufen
ach so lebt stdc brauer ok
libgcc, na meinetwegen, apk add, wie installiert man das unter, ok, libgcc und das andere heißt
std c++ ok warte mal auscheben ach so das ist jetzt in invariant
ok kunden feinde welle tq package installt ja das kann man dass das das soll soll weg
Da konnte man doch jetzt irgendwie sowas setzen.
Invariant.
Das kann man doch irgendwie auch setzen.
Auf der Kommandozeile.
Weiß da jemand?
Wir fragen ChatGPT.
Wir wipecoden uns jetzt hier durch.
set on dotnet cli
ja okay ja auch gut kann ich auch mit leben export dotnet invariant 1
wo es kommt heilt kaputt gcc not found in path
wir haben uns an den error eros durch okay wir haben ein binary also gehen wir mal hin nach temp
wo habe ich das hier plus 2000 bester name da ist gleich scheint bild da ist es
moment so richtig
Moment, ist das überhaupt das richtige Programm jetzt?
15.37 Uhr, ja?
Hä, was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
Ich dachte, das kompiliert er dann mit ein.
Ich dachte, das kompiliert er mit ein.
Ha!
Es funzt!
Guck mal.
Da haben wir so eine Alpine kompiliert.
Okay, wir haben keine,
so gut wie keine Dependencies.
Ich hoffe, dass ist jetzt alles statisch da ein...
äh...
kompiliert.
Läuft es jetzt nur, weil ich es bei mir installiert hab?
Probieren wir nochmal aus.
Das müssen wir jetzt nochmal testen.
Also, wir haben das jetzt gebildet.
Jetzt machen wir nochmal hier...
Ubuntu...
Hier.
Ubuntu 12.04.
Lob.
Bild.
Program.
Ne.
Sonst nicht.
Okay, dann hab ich keinen blassen Schimmer.
Scheiß drauf. Wir haben uns sowieso krass
wieder sidetracked, dass wir alles gemacht haben.
Bloß nicht, dass wir das ausprobieren wollen.
So, jetzt aber.
C-Sharp Features.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
What's new in C-Sharp 14?
Extension Members, da freue ich mich schon seit Jahren drauf.
Muss mal kurz Licht bei mir anmachen.
Da freue ich mich schon seit Jahren drauf, seit ihr das angekündigt habt.
Also, was ist in C-Sharp? Ich versuche das mal zu erklären.
Was es in C Sharp ja schon ziemlich lange gibt, ist Extension Methods.
Extension Methods in C Sharp, ich muss mir das mal kurz rauskopieren, weil ich da die Syntax auch immer aus dem Kopf nicht hinkriege.
Was ist das für ein ewig langes, ja, das ist ein gutes Beispiel hier.
also was was ja schon relativ lange geht in dort stellen euch mal vor es gibt eine klasse wie
machen wir mal ein anderes beispiel war ein anderes beispiel wir haben eine liste ja also
wir haben hier beispielsweise liste gleich new lists int und wir wollen jetzt auf dieser liste
brauchen wir noch irgendwie die möglichkeit zum nicht so aus dort gibt schon für chat okay das
eindeutig jede liste hat diese methode gebraucht die gibt es ja standardmäßig
nicht so und was man jetzt machen könnte was man jetzt machen kann immer noch
auch mit extension members ist dass man sagt extensions nimmt sich hier die
liste und man könnte auch liste auf thema kann sagt schon einmal
freut chat list so was mir jetzt hier drinnen machen ist wir gehen die liste durch
ja da kommt jetzt hier
so das ist das eindeutig das wollte ich schon immer als extension method haben und jetzt kann
ich aufrufen list punkt chat und es funktioniert und man sieht daran diese liste diese klasse hier
list die ist aus der standard library und ich habe die jetzt erweitert um eine methode so was
bräuchte meiner meinung nach übrigens auch c++ dass man beispielsweise die standard string klasse
erweitern könnte oder sowas das wäre mega nice wenn es da gäbe aber gibt es
leider nicht in sich ab gibt es das schon richtig lange man kann quasi auf
klassen die nicht von einem selber sind oder man kann klassen die die man nicht
selbst programmiert hat methoden hinzufügen das benutzen die auch an
total vielen stellen im framework selbst beispielsweise bei locker methoden oder
dieser dieser eihaus bilder in asp.net core haben ganz viele extension messe
hinten dran ja also auch ganz viele interfaces extended ursprünglich haben das ganze glaube ich
mal mit link ursprünglich kam das ganze mal mit link man sieht ja auch die ganzen link
methoden sind alles extension methods eines meiner erinnerung nach das geht ganz lange
schon dass das das geht das geht seit dotnet oder sites dotnet framework 4 oder so oder
seit sie schafft 3 das ist glücklich es geht richtig lange schon was nicht geht ist zum
beispiel hier eine statische methode hinzuzufügen oder aber wir machen mal eine eigene klasse ja
Wir gehen jetzt mal davon aus, es gibt hier eine Klasse, die sich Chatter nennt.
Und die, was kann die denn?
Die kann sagen, Public, Public, Void, Hello oder Say Hello.
Oder Say String Message, genau, das kann das Ding.
So, Bässe.
Das ist alles, was das Ding kann.
Wer kann das Ding nicht?
Wir wollen ihm jetzt ein paar neue Sachen beibringen
Also was wir dem Chatter
Mit
Chatter gleich New Chatter
Aktuell können wir darauf nur aufrufen
Say
So
Mit Extension Methods
Hätte man der Klasse jetzt
Auch wenn die nicht von einem selbst ist
ja wie gesagt die ist in irgendeiner anderen library wir verschieben wir
schieben jetzt einfach mal wie musik das würde ich das würde ich egal
als hat meine tastatur geleckt oder und wir können jetzt erweitern ja also man
kann nur noch mal wieder das beispiel zu bringen extensions ist egal wie das heißt ich kann jetzt
hier sagen ich will jetzt nicht nur sagen sie sondern so say hello zum beispiel so dann sage
ich ich möchte die klasse chatter erweitern und dann kann man dann da drin sagen so hier was
verkehrt ach so public jetzt kann ich sagen hier
hallo und dann rufen wir auf chat chat.de also jetzt jetzt habe ich auf
der chat klasse habe ich jetzt hier auch noch sehr hallo als extension messer
Das sieht man hier oben an diesem Pile.
Das ist eine ExtendedMath.
Das geht schon ganz lange.
Machen wir hier noch String, Message.
Jetzt haben wir quasi eine Klasse erweitert,
um eine Methode, ohne dass wir irgendwas mit der Klasse an sich zu tun haben.
Die kommt gar nicht von uns.
Ja, die kann aus der Library oder sonst wo kommen.
Das geht schon ganz lange.
Was nicht geht ist, wenn ich sage, hey, ich hätte gerne, dass Chatter eine statische Methode hat.
Oder ich hätte gerne, dass unser Chatter eine Variable hat.
So wie hier beispielsweise Emoji gleich Flugzeug oder so.
das geht nicht das haben sie jetzt hinzugefügt mit c-sharp 14 da gibt es
jetzt nämlich extension members operator operator gehen auch genau man kann jetzt
bald so ähnliche sachen so so eklige sachen wie in c++ machen und so was das
hat voll abartig würde ich erst gar nicht mit anfangen
Wieso verwendet dann die SayHello-Methode überhaupt das static Keyword?
Weil Extension Methods immer static sein mussten.
So Convention quasi.
Weil unter der Haube wird dieser Aufruf...
Wartet mal, wie können...
Man konnte es doch irgendwie decompilen lassen.
Also unter der haube ist das ist es eigentlich dieser aufruf extensions punkt say hello
chatter
Also das transferiert er also der macht unter der haube aus dem hier
Das da deswegen muss das static sein
also ist das ist einfach nur so syntaktik sugar oder so schön dass man das so schreiben kann und
wie gesagt das geht schon ganz lange aber was man auch schon damit sieht ist irgendwelche felder
variablen und static methoden und was kriegt man da nicht dran das heißt bis jetzt weil mit
C Sharp 14, kann man jetzt
Extension Members machen.
Und das habe ich selbst noch nie benutzt.
Das ist jetzt Premiere. Also kann sein,
dass ich das erstmal nicht checke.
Genau. Man kann jetzt, soweit ich weiß,
ähm,
wir haben ja sogar hier Beispiele
drin.
Genau. Man kann Properties
Extenden.
Man kann Methoden Extenden.
Das, was die ganze Zeit schon ging.
Man kann Static-Methoden, Static-Properties und Operator.
Boah, das ist halt richtig abartig.
Du kannst beispielsweise bei einer bestehenden Klasse einen Operator overloaden,
irgendwie, dass man dann schreiben kann, Chatter, so, oder sowas.
Das erinnert mich ja fast schon an C++, Alter.
Shit.
das könnte ich könnte ich auch verlauten jetzt
ok kopieren wir uns das mal raus das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren
schapler man hätte sich glaube ich auch irgendwie hier das kompilieren können ich glaube jetpilot
aus und die compiler wo man das dann ganz gut sieht du kannst du kannst du equals über das
total abgedreht so also wir machen das immer der reihe nach das hier kommt weg also wie ist ich
mache diese ganzen comments da wir machen jetzt in extension member erstmal okay ich muss das
mal hier weg machen dass ich das checke also public static class das ist wahrscheinlich
egal wie das ding heißt das nenne ich mal hier extensions so es ist generic das lassen wir auch
mal weg ein chat und der chat kriegt jetzt ein neues public pool ach so
schreibt man das dann die syntax ist echt gewöhnungsbedürftig public pool und
da wollen wir jetzt so was haben wir hier im oji oder so oder avatar im oji
Es sollte ein String sein.
Kann ich da jetzt auch Get Set machen?
This member is not allowed.
Okay, ich habe irgendwas verkehrt gemacht.
Moment, das ist jetzt...
Ah, das geht nur Getter, ne?
Setter gibt's quasi nicht.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Okay, also man kann kein
richtiges Property dran hauen.
Ah, nee, das geht nicht.
Muss dann auf ein bestehendes Feld gehen?
Äh.
Okay, wir machen jetzt einfach mal eins, dass man...
Emoji hier.
Dissorted Face.
Eindeutig, das haben wir jetzt gebraucht.
Okay, also jetzt zumindest haben wir jetzt der Chatter.
wenn wir den jetzt ausgeben, können wir jetzt sagen
Avatar Emoji.
Das passt. Wir können das mal ausführen.
Müssen wir hier hin.
Repos.
Net.
Run.
Da müssen wir jetzt so ein
komisches Emoji sehen.
Da.
Okay, das funzt.
Also, man kann, also das ist
Das ist nur Getter.
Nur reine, reine Getter.
Wenn ich jetzt da ein Set für bauen will, geht natürlich nicht.
Kann man in C-Sharp Methoden und Klassen mit Emo...
Ich glaube nicht.
Das habe ich mal gefragt.
Da habe ich einen Gutschein gewonnen bei Microsoft.
Als ich die Frage mal gestellt habe.
Das geht nicht.
Ich habe mal die Frage gestellt bei irgendeinem .NET Livestream, wann gibt es Emoji-Variablen und das haben sie beantwortet, haben gesagt, irgendwie nicht geplant und da habe ich irgendwie einen Gutschein gewonnen für den Microsoft, für diesen .NET Fanartikel-Store. Habe ich bis heute nicht eingelöst, gilt wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr.
Na, alle Leute, die Fragen gestellt haben,
die im Stream vorgelesen wurden,
haben so einen kleinen Gutschein gewonnen,
dass man halt Anreize hatte, Fragen zu stellen.
Ja, gibt es.
Gibt es.
Es gibt beispielsweise das C-Sharp
Superman T-Shirt.
Äh, Shirt.
Shirt.
Das da.
Zum Beispiel gibt es da.
Also, das funzt so.
Okay, ehrlich gesagt,
Chat, fällt euch irgendwie spontan
eine gute
anwendungsszenario für extension getter proxys ein vielleicht vielleicht um
sachen die schon da sind anders zu formatieren
also sagen sagen wir mal doch ich habe eine idee ich habe eine idee wofür
dafür das sinnvoll ist guck mal wenn ich mal vor die hätte jetzt hier first name
last name gibt es jetzt hier drauf so und ich möchte jetzt auch noch eine full name
extension west oder extension property haben dann könnte ich hier sagen source
Firstname plus SourceLastname.
Dafür ist es vielleicht ganz sinnig.
Okay, es gibt Firstname, es gibt Lastname,
aber Fullname gibt es nicht.
Das habe ich jetzt nachträglich hinzugefügt.
Ja, dafür mal...
Ach so.
Ich bin da ein Kacknoob.
Ich sollte vielleicht nochmal was setzen erstmal.
First Name.
Okay, Chris.
Last Name Chris.
Die AI ist nicht so schlau.
Und jetzt kommt dann da raus Chris 0w.
Dafür ist es glaube ich ganz sinnig.
Und der Setter könnte theoretisch den Input String bei einem Space Player...
Ja, das geht doch wahrscheinlich dann nicht, oder?
das kann man mal ausprobieren ob das ist ich glaube nicht dass das funktioniert
also war mal hierhin so zack
jetzt set
ich weiß gar nicht wie die richtige syntax dafür ist ehrlich gesagt jetzt
jetzt muss man so machen
Und dann muss man hinten auch den...
Und Set?
Nee, man kann ja keine Setter machen.
Das funzt nicht.
Oder doch?
Aber Field kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, oder?
Wie, das Funs doch?
Das ist übrigens auch ein neues, die Sharp 14 Feature.
Moment, das mit Zettern funktioniert doch?
das von stop
man muss es bloß komplett schreiben jetzt geht es doch wieder nicht
das member ist noch laut in den extension blog was was denn genau
das member ist dort in einer extension blog was was was was wir
hier fehlt viel ist ein bisschen oder was
Ah ja, okay
Das ist nicht erlaubt
Ah, aber, ach, verstehe
Okay, aber was ich jetzt machen könnte ist
Okay, das macht Sinn
Also, Moment, Moment, Moment
Also, machen wir nochmal so den hier
So, was ich jetzt machen könnte ist
Ich könnte jetzt sagen
Value
Also sprich, wenn es eine set hat
Das ist glaube ich, was der Chat auch gemeint hat
Splitte ich am Leerzimmer
Alter, ist ja gut, AI
Value gleich Split
Und dann sagen wir hier
Was weiß ich, Temp
Perfekt
Genau, Source First
Temp 0, das da
Sagen wir dann
Ah, das funzt aber auch nicht, oder?
Doch, das funzt
das Funs.
Okay, das ist
in der Tat ganz nice.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt sagen,
Chatter
gleich Fullname
gleich
Max Pogu.
Und wenn ich dann
Chatter Firstname
ausgebe, dann
kommt dann da Max raus.
Ha!
Das ist doch ganz nice.
Ich glaube, damit kann man was anfangen.
Das ist jetzt das Erste, was ich mir so aus den Fingern gesaugt habe.
Aber das ist echt nice.
Und alles möglich bei Klassen, die es schon gibt.
Also ich könnte jetzt beispielsweise hier Console irgendwie sowas hinzufügen.
Macht jetzt wenig Sinn, aber das ist echt cool.
Ja
Ich gehe davon aus
Das ist was, was man nicht oft braucht
Aber wenn man es dann mal braucht
Ist man froh, dass es da ist
Das ist echt cool
Das gefällt mir
So
Fühlt sich illegal
Bisschen illegal fühlt es sich an
So, was haben wir jetzt als nächstes
Extension Methods
Okay, das probieren wir jetzt nochmal genauso aus.
Also eine ganz normale Extension-Method.
Also quasi das, was wir die ganze Zeit schon machen konnten, nur in neuer Syntax.
Also Chatter.
Ach nee.
Einfach gar nichts.
Also hier irgendwie Say Hello.
jetzt noch mal und dann würde ich jetzt würde ich jetzt sagen hier ist ja
console console right hello und dann source punkt say say message also das
ist im prinzip das gleiche wie wir vorher hatten
say hello lul we gleich über vorher hatten genau schreibt der hallo davor
nur mit der neuen syntax irgendwie finde ich die syntax bisschen bisschen weiß
ich nicht also ich verstehe warum das hier so
nestet haben die müssen ja dafür sorgen dass es keine doppeldeutige syntax gibt
Deswegen ist das wahrscheinlich hier in diesem
Extension-Dings irgendwie...
Aber wisst ihr, warum braucht es das
hier eigentlich noch? Jetzt mal ernsthaft, warum kann man
nicht sowas hier machen?
Das wäre doch nicer, als da noch so eine komische Klasse
drumherum.
Ah, ich weiß warum.
Ich weiß warum.
Es könnte ja...
Es könnte ja mehrere
Extensions
geben davon also gewöhnungsbedürftig was die erste quasi schon mal zwei
eindrückungsebenen bis es überhaupt losgeht ein neues youtube-video kommt
Oh, weiß ich nicht.
Erstmal mal einen ganzen Kram hier auf die Reihe kriegen.
So, also das ist wie gehabt Extension Methods.
So, und jetzt kommt das richtig coole.
man kann Static Extension
Members
hinzufügen.
Also zum Beispiel
ich kann jetzt sagen
ich hätte gerne
dass mein Chatter
eine Login Methode
eine Login ist ein doofes Beispiel
eine Create Methode hat, okay?
Der ein paar spezielle Dinger macht für mich.
Kann man eigentlich
auch einen Konstruktor
Extenten?
Nee, oder? Das geht bestimmt nicht.
Das geht wahrscheinlich nicht.
Konstrukt der Extenten müsste ja irgendwie so aussehen
oder so, aber das geht nicht.
Okay, also ich will quasi
eine statische Create-Methode haben.
Wie würde man das machen?
Achso, im Prinzip genauso, nur dass man static davor schreibt.
Static void, hier create, string first, string last, so irgendwie sowas und dann würde man
sagen, ne create, da kommt als, links ein Chatter zurück.
dann hier return
first
das ist jetzt ein bisschen bescheuert
weil ich es auch oben setzen kann
aber nur mal zum ausprobieren
so und jetzt könnte ich quasi sagen
chatter create
max lul
wenn ich den jetzt
ausgebe
ah Moment jetzt hab ich eine Idee
reverse
hier mein full name und wir gerade noch mal hier rein so hat er set kommt weg
braunet aber noch besser und jetzt kann ich hier sagen chat gleich
hole name und jetzt kommt max lull raus genau man quasi so eine so eine factory methode hinzugefügt
statisch das ist weiß ganz ehrlich ich glaube das ist das was ich von den neuen sachen am ehesten
brauche neben extension methods das ist nice da kann man zum beispiel auch so sachen wie früher
gab sie diese bitmap klasse in windows forms da habe ich öfters gewünscht warum gibt es da
nicht so was wie irgendwie create from position oder irgendwie sowas das ist das ist wirklich
cool das gefällt mir das werde ich öfters verwenden da könnte man jetzt zum beispiel
auch überlegt mal was man also es gibt hier konsole es gibt ja konsole right line und es
gibt konsole ride so und mal angenommen ich will jetzt was was könnte ich noch
haben haben wollen format oder irgendwie sowas ja
resource generators damit habe ich noch nicht beschäftigt
right emoji wollen wir haben okay oder ich weiß ich ich habe eine idee was wir
machen ich habe eine idee was wir machen
also schmeißen wir das mal weg so und jetzt exten wir konsole
ach so
ach das geht nicht
das aber doof
ach so und so geht das dann console so und jetzt haben wir so sie hier
RIDELINE ALARM
oder sowas.
Ja.
String Message.
RIDE ALARM machen wir jetzt.
So.
Und dann sagen wir jetzt hier
ANSI CONSOLE
RIDE LINE
oder RIDE MARKUP.
Dann machen wir nochmal RED.
oh, ups, message, ah, void, ok, das kompiliert und jetzt kann ich sagen, console, write alarm,
lul weh weh weh weh
und jetzt hab ich
und jetzt wird das in rot geprintet
Alarm
das ist nice
das werde ich glaube ich öfters verwenden
quasi an schon bestehende Sachen
statische Methoden noch dran pappen
das ist schick
das gefällt mir
Chat seht ihr auch den Anwendungsfall
bei euch dafür.
Also ich denke, das ist nice.
Das gefällt mir.
So, was haben wir sonst noch Schönes?
Operator.
Okay, jetzt wird's abartig, Leute.
Jetzt wird's abartig.
Machen wir das mal kurz hier zurück.
So, wir überschreiben jetzt mal Operator.
Programmierst du gerne in Python?
Nee, das hält sich in Grenzen
Ich würde tatsächlich, wenn ich könnte
Ruby bevorzugen
Aber Ruby ist halt überhaupt nicht mehr verbreitet
Und kein Mensch macht mehr was in Ruby
Python nur, wenn es sich nicht vermeiden lässt
So, guck mal
Wir können jetzt Operator overloaden
Das ist ja richtig abartig
cannot return wollt moment jetzt bin ich bin verwirrt was zum in
kantin in return okay das geht ich weiß immer noch nicht genau was ich machen will
Ach, Chatter.
Okay, okay.
Ich glaube, ich habe eine Idee.
Wir können...
Wir tun jetzt mal so.
Kann man das da overloaden?
Kann man.
Boah, das gibt eklige C++-Syntax, Alter.
Ups
Ich kann jetzt hier sagen
console
Nenomen moment da muss der muss was returnen der muss was returnen der kann kein volt return
Das ist jetzt
Overloading bei extension ich hab keine ahnung wie man es nennen soll
Okay, machen wir jetzt mal was ganz abartiges.
Wir sagen jetzt einfach Chatter1.
First Name.
Count.
Plus.
Chatter2.
Last Name.
Count.
Das ergibt gar keinen Sinn.
Ich weiß, ja.
Ich weiß, es gibt gar keinen Sinn.
Ich will es so ausbrieren.
So, das ist hier Chatter 1.
Das ist Chatter 2.
Pog.
Poggers.
So, und jetzt kann man dann sagen...
Moment.
Okay, jetzt will man...
Jetzt kann man sagen, Chatter 1.
Chatter 2.
Alter, ist das eklig.
So, und da müsst ihr jetzt rauskommen.
Warte mal, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
11 müsst ihr da rauskommen.
10, ich hab mich verzählt.
Es funktioniert.
Boah, was eine abartige Syntax, Mann.
Da kann man ja ganz viel eklige Sachen damit reiben.
Aber richtig abartige Sachen kann man damit machen
Das ist eine gute Idee
Sowas könnte man damit machen, ja
Ja, stimmt, das muss ich mal ausprobieren
Das ist, nicht, dass ich es verwenden will
Niemand würde das so schreiben
Aber nur so gucken, dass es funktioniert.
Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Da können wir das auch gleich mal generic machen.
Pass mal auf, 6-Head-Time jetzt.
5-Head reicht dafür nicht mehr.
So, wir machen jetzt mal eine Liste.
New List.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Nicht List of Chatter.
List of Int.
So, okay.
So, wir wollen jetzt bei der Liste...
Lass mal kurz überlegen.
Ich will den Plus-Operator überschreiben.
Das heißt, ich brauche bei einem...
Wir machen es danach mal was generic.
Ich bekomme eine Liste...
Eine Liste Int.
Und ich bekomme einen Int.
Das geht nicht.
Achso, weil es immer noch Chatter ist hier oben.
Naja.
list in so und jetzt kann ich sagen
hörst
moment
das ist jetzt hat das eine referenz ist
keine kopie
ich müsste mir jetzt erstmal kopieren
also weil wenn ich jetzt nämlich sagen
first and i das funzt zwar, na wobei, okay, schön ist es nicht, aber es würde funktionieren und jetzt kann ich schreiben, wir machen jetzt erstmal hier eine for each Schleife, hier list i, oh, geben wir das aus, machen wir jetzt noch ein paar Sachen rein hier, 1, 2, 3,
Und jetzt sage ich List plus 69.
Ah, muss ich List gleich List plus 69 sagen?
Ah, Moment.
List plus gleich 69.
So, und jetzt müsste rauskommen 1, 2, 3, 69.
Das Funst.
Man kann sein...
Okay.
Wir appenden.
Das ist quasi jetzt der Append-Operator.
Versteht kein Mensch, der es liest,
weil niemand sowas hier definiert hat.
Aber das funktioniert.
Für manche Sachen ist es bestimmt nice.
Ja, dafür ist es jetzt vielleicht nicht.
So, und jetzt müssen wir das Ganze noch generic machen, Leute.
Wie machen wir das jetzt generic?
T.
T?
Moment, wie mache ich das jetzt richtig?
Converse?
Ne.
Wartet mal.
Wie würde ich das jetzt gescheit machen?
Nee, das muss T sein.
Nicht Int.
Muss T sein.
Dann ergibt es ja auch Sinn.
So, und jetzt funzt das mit jeder
Liste im Endeffekt.
Das heißt, ich könnte jetzt sogar eine Liste
machen mit Strings.
Lul.
Keg.
String.
So, und jetzt könnte ich hier sagen,
adde noch Kekkel.
Plus gleich Kekkel.
Ach, das geht jetzt nicht.
Ähm, warum geht das jetzt nicht?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Aber was ich doch machen kann, ist...
Das funzt nämlich.
Ach, Moment.
Hä?
Jetzt blick, jetzt blick.
Ich nehm ja nur jetzt vorbei.
Source?
Warte mal.
Ne, mit Source hat das ja überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Das kann ich weglassen.
Ah.
Ich weiß, woran das liegt.
Plus gibt es doch schon.
Bei einem String.
Muss ich vielleicht sagen?
Kekkel
Pluslist?
Ne.
Ich glaube, wenn schon
ein Operator overloaded ist,
dann hat er Probleme damit.
Dann nimmt er den, den es schon gibt.
By the way, was kommt denn jetzt da eigentlich raus?
Das war eine blöde Frage.
Was ist denn jetzt B?
Was ist B?
Ah, okay.
Okay, der Plus ist schon überladen.
Das heißt, wir können das jetzt
im Float oder so ausprobieren.
1.1 und warte mal machen wir noch mal hier list
for each
so jetzt haben wir hier list was jetzt hier falsch dran
Double, ja ja ist ja gut.
List plus gleich
6.9
Das für uns. Okay, der checkt das nicht
Mit dem
Mit Strings, weil irgendwie plus da schon überladen ist
Vielleicht muss man das klammern, dass er es checkt
haben wir noch mal hier den auch den kram mit den strings
wartet mal
vielleicht muss man das irgendwie klammern dass man irgendwie sagt list los gleich eckel
das geht ja nicht dass man das irgendwie klammern muss ok
Okay, nee, das kann's nicht sein.
Also, fetzt das nicht.
Mal angenommen, ich will nur, dass das mit Zahlen funktioniert.
Wie würde ich denn das machen?
Also, mal angenommen, ich will das...
Da brauche ich irgendeinen so einen Constrain oder sowas.
Where?
Nee, äh...
Das geht wahrscheinlich nicht.
oder hier wo muss ich das hinschreiben
Wir machen das da mal in ein Double raus.
Wo muss ich das?
Vermutlich bei Extensions nicht verfügbar? Vielleicht.
Moment, das googeln wir jetzt mal.
C-Sharp
Extension Members
Constraints
Aha!
Das Auto complete by Rider
checkt es einfach nur nicht.
I number
I number of T
So
Und jetzt geht das mit allem,
was Zahlen sind.
Und mit Strings geht es nicht.
oder mit anderen Sachen.
Also ich kann jetzt quasi sagen,
plus gleich,
ja gut, das wird konvertiert, das funzt.
Was allerdings jetzt dann natürlich nicht funktioniert,
ist wenn das
irgendwas anderes hier, keine Ahnung,
Chatter
zum Beispiel ist.
da kann ich jetzt nicht sagen plus new chatter das funzt nicht cannot apply
das dürfte auch so nicht funzen weil
ja gut er sagt ja gibt es nicht gibt sie gibt den operator nicht an der stelle okay das macht
schon Sinn. Was will er mir eigentlich hiermit sagen?
Nice Rider!
Das ist schon echt
advanceder Shit, ey.
aber cool da habe ich mich schon wirklich jahrelang drauf gefreut das haben die mal
irgendwann angekündigt für fragt mich damals hieß es extent anything oder any extent everything
irgendwie so hieß das glaube ich und das war schon bei c sharp 10 oder so schon vier jahre
oder so her da habe ich mich damals schon darauf gefreut weil ich mir gedacht habe das ist einfach
richtig weiß und jetzt ist es da also operator overloading oder operator
extensions hätte ich persönlich jetzt nicht gebraucht aber ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass es für manche sachen doch nützlich ist
wenn wir stimmt früher oder später mal verwenden so viel keyword auch neu auch
mega nice habe ich eben ja schon mal kurz gezeigt was man jetzt machen kann
ist folgendes ich muss es mal als beispiel zeigen also guck mal wenn ich hier wenn ich
hier properties habe zum beispiel nehmen wir jetzt mal hier first name das ist ein auto
property das heißt unter der haube ich gucke ob ich euch das zeigen kann sharp lab
guck unter der haube also wir haben hier ein auto property das heißt unter der haube werden
hier ganz normal private fields angelegt und getter und setter seht ihr das first name ist
ein getter mit hier einem automatisch generierten backing field und setter oder value eingeschrieben
wird also im prinzip das hier wird unter der haube zu dem hier okay last name kommt raus
so und das problem bisher war immer wenn man das jetzt teilweise nur machen will also wenn ich
jetzt sage zum beispiel ich will denn ich will den getter jetzt hier noch definieren so dann
hat er gesagt, oh ne, darfst du nicht.
Ich meine, ich mache das auch gerade
falsch, ne.
Genau. Hier,
return John.
Und dann hat er gesagt,
das geht nicht. Also in C Sharp 9 ging
das nicht. Dann hat er gesagt, ey, wenn
du einen Getter,
also,
wenn du einen Getter definierst,
dann musst du
das von Hand machen. Das heißt, ich musste
damals dann hier private,
private string,
first name gleich,
so, bla, und dann hier setzen.
In C Sharp 10
darf man jetzt
einen Custom Getter machen
und einfach nur noch set hinschreiben.
Dann,
also ich glaube, das ist seit C Sharp 10,
dann geht das jetzt. Also sprich,
der kann weiterhin Compiler
generieren, dass es
ein Backing Field gibt. Was man
jetzt allerdings machen kann, die große Preisfrage
ist natürlich, wenn ich jetzt kein Custom
Getter machen will, sondern ein
Custom Setter. Also lassen
wir mal das hier weg.
Ich will ein Custom Setter machen. Ich will zum Beispiel
checken, ob der First Name
nicht anfängt mit Max. Da gibt es
eine Exception, wenn er mit Max anfängt.
So, und da kann man jetzt
schreiben,
Value gibt es ja schon lange. Value ist
immer der Wert,
der auf, also wenn jetzt jemand hier schreibt
äh
hier, Chatter
hier Chatter, First Name
gleich Blub, dann ist Blub
der Value, das ist
quasi so eine temporäre
Magic Variable, wo immer der Wert
rechts neben dem Gleichheitszeichen drin steht
so, aber es gibt jetzt was
Neues und zwar es gibt jetzt ein neues Keyword
das nennt sich Field
und Field ist immer die Referenz
auf dieses
per Compiler, was der Compiler anlegt, Backing
field dass ich kann jetzt den custom setter machen und weiterhin kompil die sachen generieren lassen
was halt richtig nice ist dadurch dass ich mir diesen ganzen schritt hier spar so und da kann
ich jetzt zum beispiel sagen hier setter machen wir mal an
value start max dann frau keck exception beste wer kennt sie nicht
und ansonsten wird es gesetzt.
Field ist theoretisch das,
ja, ja, also
der Compiler generiert dann sowas hier für mich.
Primates, String, Name,
also hier sowas da, das heißt dann
k underscore underscore
Backing Field und sowas.
So heißt das dann
unter der Haube. Genau.
Also der Compiler
legt unter der Haube sowas an.
und setzt das dann hier.
Field ist die Referenz auf dieses per Compiler
Generated Backing Field.
Das habe ich auch nur gemacht, soweit ich
weiß, dass du sowas hier machen kannst. Also
sprich, manchmal willst du ja Custom
Setter, das war glaube ich so die Hauptmotivation dahinter.
Du willst ja manchmal Custom Setter
haben,
weil du checken willst, ob der Value
valid ist. Ja, ob das okay
ist, dass der Vorname,
das darf halt nicht mit Max anfangen.
Und sobald du das gemacht hast, musstest du immer die gesamte Zeremonie hier schreiben.
Das gibt's jetzt erst, ja.
Ja.
Das gibt's jetzt erst.
Das ist auch sehr nice.
Jetzt nochmal zum Vergleich, damit das mal vielleicht ein bisschen besser rauskommt.
Also, wenn ich sowas hätte machen wollen früher, hätte ich sowas hier schreiben müssen.
Private String Name Get Return Name Set und dann hier Name gleich Value.
Also so wäre das früher gewesen, okay?
Oder so, bisschen kürzer.
So hätte man das früher schreiben müssen.
Das kann man sich hier oben jetzt sparen.
Eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Ja, und das hier kann man sich auch sparen.
Field.
Das geht übrigens auch hier drinnen, ne?
Das geht auch im Getter.
Ich kann auch im Getter sagen, Field.
Und dann könnte ich irgendwas checken.
Aber im Getter kommt das nicht so oft vor, ehrlich gesagt.
Also wüsste ich jetzt nicht, was ich da machen will.
Man könnte höchstens sagen, okay, vielleicht...
Was weiß ich, wenn das klein...
Fällt mir jetzt nur nicht mal ein sinnvolles Beispiel ein.
Kann man mit der neuen Kurzform dann noch auf die automatisch generierten Names zugreifen?
Du meinst jetzt von woanders?
du meinst jetzt dass man hier von irgendwie darauf zu nehmen das geht nicht das geht nicht
du kannst nur auf first name zugreifen viel gibt es viel gibt es nur innerhalb davon also wenn du
access zu einem privaten feld brauchst aus der anderen methode raus und dann musste nach wie
vor die Zeremonie machen. Also es gibt nicht so was wie this first name private oder sowas.
Oder irgendwie sowas, das gibt es nicht. Das ist neu, finde ich ist auch ein sehr nice Feature.
excellent
field keyword ja hier gibt es ja auch ein beispiel genau im prinzip mehr oder weniger
das was wir gerade gemacht haben implicit span conversions juckt mich überhaupt nicht
anbauen generic types and name of
man kann jetzt den den type ohne den typ zu schreiben bei name of reinschreiben
ok whatever simple lambda parameters mit modifiers man kann jetzt kommt
reff in out okay das ist in der tat ganz praktisch das ist auch das erste woran
ich gedacht habe wer jetzt noch wer jetzt noch sie schafft was ist das sie
schafft 3 und sie schafft sie schafft fünf oder so was da im framework das
letzte war was so portet wurde was die schab 7 ich weiß es gar nicht der hat
echt gelitten ja es sind ja auch viele richtig richtig also richtig coole
sachen reingekommen beispielsweise diese ganze pattern matching geschichte das ist
ziemlich
ja hier hätte ich aber auch dran gedacht dass man jetzt beispielsweise hier zwei
pass verwenden kann weil zwei pass verwende man ein parameter und man konnte bisher hier
in so einer lambda expression keine out parameter verwenden das ist ganz nice
dass es jetzt geht
partial members juckt mich nicht das ist wahrscheinlich wichtig für generators oder sowas
user die fein kommt es sein wenn ich ja absolut keine ahnung was das sein soll
Man kann jetzt plusgleich überladen oder wie?
Ja gut, schön, dass man das kann.
Jetzt gibt es das null conditional assignment.
ach ja das ist natürlich nice das habe ich schon in irgendeinem web webcast oder so gesehen das
ist natürlich nice das heißt chat guck mal was jetzt geht ist aber das mit weg hier war
chatter gleich new chatter irgend ebbes so max null so wenn ich jetzt hier etwas zuweisen will
first name ist gleich john perfekter so muss das sein warte mal first name ist gleich john
wenn ich jetzt nicht weiß ob das hier vielleicht null ist dann kann ich jetzt hier ein fragezeichen
davor machen heißt selbst wenn das hier jetzt wenn ich jetzt hier chatter gleich null dann
crasht es jetzt nicht wenn ich es aus für kein crash kein null point exception wenn ich das
fragezeichen weg mache dann weil ist ja null das ist praktisch das sind so kleine dinge wo ich mir
manchmal denke sowas könnte microsoft mehr machen und vielleicht so diese feature flut die es die
letzten sechs sieben jahre gegeben hat die nächsten paar die sharp version ein bisschen
einheitlicher machen und dafür nur so ein paar kleine features wie das also ist nämlich mein
die haben ja so viele sachen eingeführt teilweise über mehrere versionen hinweg ich fände es
eigentlich ziemlich nice, wenn die
nächsten 2.30 Sharp-Versionen, also die nächsten
2-3 Jahre, wenn die sich einfach nur mal
hinsetzen würden und so kleine Sachen
hier einführen und das,
was sie eingeführt haben über die letzten
6-7 Jahre
nochmal ein bisschen durchdenken
und das rund machen
an vielen Stellen.
Und sich überlegen,
okay, vielleicht wäre es gut,
wenn man da auch noch das und das und jenes und das
und ein runderes Gesamtbild gibt.
Manche wirken so ein bisschen mit heißer Nadel gestrickt.
Aber das ist gut. Das gefällt mir.
Nice.
Das war es mit C-Sharp Features.
Dann eine Sache, die ich noch unbedingt ausprobieren will, ist die neue Websocket-Geschichte in ASP.NET Core.
Result Types und Union Types brauchen wir.
Und was ich ja auch sehr schade finde, dass sie ihr Messaging für ASP.NET Core abgeblasen haben.
So Message Broadcasten in seiner ASP.NET Core Anwendung.
Spring Boot hat das?
Äh, ASP.NET Core nicht. Brauche mir irgendeine extra Library für.
Ja, das wären so drei Sachen, die ich mir tatsächlich wünschen würde.
eingebautes Messaging in ASP.NET Core, Result Types
und, also Result Types
Schrägstrich Optional Types und
oder auch Error Types
und Union Types, ja, das wäre sehr nice.
Okay, machen wir mal hier
Was meinst du mit Messaging in .NET?
Moment.
Guck mal, das ist eine Java-Anwendung.
Und hier gibt es
einen Background-Task,
der, ich hoffe, das stimmt,
was ich hier dir überhaupt erzähle.
Ich glaube, das gibt es hier nämlich gar nicht mehr.
habe ich das hier rausgeschmissen
der sehr clever max wollte ich das zeigen aber bringt gar nichts weil es immer drin ist toll
Moment, das ist das Falsche.
Das ist das Falsche? Das wollte ich doch gar nicht.
Das da wollte ich.
Ja, hier, das meine ich.
Also guck mal, du hast hier eine Springboot-Anwendung, da läuft im Hintergrund ein Task einmal in der Sekunde.
So, und der macht dann da Dinge, der generiert irgendwelche Random-To-Dos, zum Beispiel, ja, Random-To-Dos, und das ist das Background-Task.
Und der Background-Task, der will jetzt allen anderen Teilen der Anwendung Bescheid sagen, dass es ein neues To-Do gibt.
Und da hat Spring Boot, hat hier sowas drin, das nennt sich Application Event Publisher.
das ist quasi so eine Message Bus
Application Wide
da kannst du von einem Teil der Anwendung
was Publishen und das Empfangen
am anderen Ende der Anwendung
und hier Publish der
neues Event und ich glaube
hier bei
bei den
im Websocket Händler
oder auch nicht
...
dass das in spring gut eingebaut ist und das finde ich geil wenn sowas in der
spd core auch drin wäre ja du kannst das schon nachbauen
du kannst das schon nachbauen das ist auch gar nicht so viel aber ich fände es
halt wenn sowas hier eingebaut wäre
dass er das alles direkt schon in registert hat hast beim start up und dann
nur noch sagen muss er hier ist ein händler und ich publish jetzt bauen kann man das auch was
fertiges nehmen was du schon kann aber ich fände das nice wenn das wenn das fix und fertig eingebaut
wäre und dann noch option option optional types result types error types und union types aber das
irgendwann mal haben fällt mir nichts mehr ein was was man noch bräuchten in c sharp
ok wir löschen den ganzen krempel hier mal wieder aber hier mal zu löschen zack so dort
new web ist es web oder web api ich weiß es gar nicht wenn es wir erstellen jetzt
das neue neues asp.net moment ist schon wieder verkackt schon wieder verkackt
wir wollen nicht wir wollen dort netz new web
So wir erstellen jetzt mal eine Web-API und probieren mal die neuen...
...das neue Websocket-Ding aus.
.NET 10 Champ, genau. Mal gucken wie das funzt.
so das ist minimal asp.net core beispiel .net run zack wenn hier unten curl localhost 5280
guck ich curle kommt der hallo welt zurück also gut so und jetzt mal gucken wie das mit den
Websockets funktioniert.
.NET 10 Websocket
Streams heißt das. Websocket
Stream
ASP.NET Core. Da gucken wir mal,
ob wir da ein Beispiel finden.
Ja.
Alter, was ist das für eine Farbe?
Wer hat sich denn da gedacht?
Oh, das ist eine gute Idee.
Das ist die alte Variante,
wie man es macht.
sag mal das ist AI generated oder
ne es gibt eine neue Websocket
Abstraktionsebene
so dass man
nicht mal zwingend
wenn man noch alle Tassen im Schrank behalten will
Signal A braucht für Websockets
hier gibt es ja
hier hat er ein Beispiel jetzt für drinnen
genau
ok ich kopiere mir das mal gerade
Kopier mir das mal grad
Und dann schmeißen wir die Hälfte wieder raus
Also Map
WS
Websocket Stream
Kann das sein, Chat?
Das ist AI-Slob
diese artikel die dinger gibt es überhaupt nicht die hier in dem beispiel
drinstehen
er schädel rettet
The fuck top sehr gutes hat
Create readable message stream create gibt es
Websocket?
Äh.
Wo genau ist das Problem jetzt?
Ah.
Da muss man noch mehr angeben.
Da muss man den Websocket angeben.
Dann den...
Text.
Text?
Das war's.
Okay.
Es ist zwar AI-Generator, aber es funzt halbwegs.
Reader, Writer.
Ne, wir wollen nur
Readen.
Ne, wir wollen nur Reiten. Readen wollen wir gar nicht.
Writer.
Schreiben wir jetzt einfach mal was rein.
While.
True.
Writer.
Hello World.
oder kann man da weitlein machen. Jetzt sagen wir hier task delay eine Sekunde warten. Okay.
So jetzt kann ich mich da per Websocket dran verbinden und bekommen. Eier ja geschickt.
Eben einmal in der Sekunde hoffe ich dass das stimmt was ich da gebaut habe. Weil das wäre
gehen das wäre ganz cool ok bs localhost 55 28 0
du hast app use web so geht es nicht aus dem blog mit was recht wo kommt das hin
genau das recht noch mal in wille port number also sonst wir kriegen einmal in
der sekunde a ja ja gepusht und das ohne signal a und sowas das ist das ist echt
ganz praktisch weil ich finde signal an sich ja ganz okay aber für so kleine
sachen finde ich das übelst bloatet
das ist wirklich redundant als als bedeutet korte keine websocket doch hatte
sie hatte hatten sie aber du musstest dich selbst um buffer und und chunks und
sowas kümmern guck mal die hatten hier oben noch ein beispiel ist ursprünglich
außer guckt du brauchst ihnen beide buffer muss gucken ob es im close
message ist ob es irgendwie dann drin steht dann musste irgendwelche messages
in den buffer reden und so was das war wirklich super low level
Und jetzt ist es ein bisschen einfacher.
An sich war WebSocket nicht schwierig mit ASP.NET Core.
Du hast einfach SignalR verwendet.
Das ist eine WebSocket Library von Microsoft, die das ein bisschen abstrahiert.
Und das war super easy.
Microsoft Beispiele.
Im Prinzip hast du dann sowas hier erstellt.
Und das war es fast schon.
also mit signal ist das auch easy gewesen aber ich finde es trotzdem doof dass man signal braucht
das hier finde ich jetzt eigentlich ganz nice wenn man wenn man nur einfache websocket sachen
machen will wie einmal in der sekunde ein update pushen oder keine ahnung wenn ein sensor sich
aktualisiert hat in den update pushen so was dann ist das ja nicht verkehrt und jetzt sind wir wieder
bei dem thema was ich davor hatte hätten die jetzt eine messaging library eingebaut könnte
man hier tatsächlich dann auch sagen wir warten jetzt auf ein event was irgendwo anders in der
anwendung gesendet wird und pushen dann eine websocke message was meckerte hier eigentlich
Await Using
war. Moment.
Async Destructor stellst.
Await Using war.
Bam.
Das finde ich
eigentlich
nicht verkehrt.
So.
Ich glaube, wir haben es geschafft, Chat.
Das ist alles
was Neues.
Es war ja gucke ich mir nicht an wo ich
basic gucke ich mir gar nicht und wpf
von windows form es juckt uns auch nicht
er war glaube ich auch nichts
großartiges trainer bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla das juckt auch nicht
ja chat wir haben es kannst du einmal
du meinst zu dem hier zum overview gibt es auch schon channels in amur für solche events ja aber
du musst das erst mal mitkriegen war das mal stell dir vor du hast irgendein background service so
und der background service der macht in unregelmäßigen abständen dinge und wenn
dann mal was gemacht hat und was spezielles passiert ist dann neue sensor wert oder soja
background service der fragenden sensor ab und und unregelmäßigen abständen hat der sensor hat neue
werte so und sobald neue werte gibt willst du die per websocke an den kleinen schicken der
background service denn diesen sensor checkt der läuft ja eine ganz andere ecke und du hast keine
eingebaute variante bis ohne art message bus du kannst dir das selbst stricken das ist keine
frage ja das kannst du machen manche verwenden auch mediator oder so was
aber es gibt halt nichts eingebautes wenn du was selbst machen willst mit
channels ist ja nicht so einfach da musst du dir irgendwie zumindest also
das mindeste was du machen musst ist die ein paar sachen per dependency injection
für die pendels injection registern und bei channels hast du das problem dass
ein Channel ja, du schreibst was rein
und liest es raus ist
und bei Events willst du ja eigentlich
reinschreiben und an mehreren Stellen lesen können.
Also musst du dir was selbst stricken für.
Deswegen ist es blöd, dass es das nicht gibt.
Ja, stell dir vor,
stell dir vor, man könnte hier wirklich
sowas machen.
Ups.
Äh.
Ach, ich bin blöd.
Ich hab die Klammern falsch gesetzt.
Stell dir vor, man könnte wirklich sowas hier machen.
Keine Ahnung.
Message-Bus.
Und dann könntest du hier sagen,
message bus wait oder so oder subscribe keine ahnung und dann wird es so message
wird so was hier machen das wäre doch nice wenn das ging
aber gibt es nicht gibt es zumindest nichts eingebautes
exzellent hallo die z adam
Das mit Wild True ist nicht so schön.
Nee.
Aber was willst du machen an der Stelle?
Ich will halt jede Sekunde was senden.
Da bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig.
So schaut's aus.
Chat, anstrengender Stream heute gewesen.
3 Stunden 45.
So lange waren wir lange nicht mehr am Start.
Aber ich glaube, jetzt haben wir alles durch.
C-Sharp und .NET 10 einmal im
Stelldurchgang
Aspire könnten wir uns noch ewig angucken
Das ist aber auch so ein Ding, ganz ehrlich, ich check
den Hype
oder das, was Microsoft gerne da Hype hätte
um Aspire nicht so genau
Mag vielleicht auch daran liegen
dass ich noch nicht 100%
also noch nicht 100%ig geklickt
hat bei mir im Kopf, wofür
genau ich eigentlich Aspire brauche.
What's new?
Ah.
Is it too late to start at
at like
26, 27? No.
Ähm.
I did my... Was heißt
eine ausbildung auf englisch hat man das das was heißt ausbildung auf englisch
training training with 25
apprenticeship
als never too late
aber mein Video ist ein bisschen älter, aber ich denke, es ist immer noch auf der Zeit
und viele, viele
Firmen suchen für ein bisschen mehr maturity
Azubis.
Azubi ist
short version of apprenticeship
like auszubildender
hast du als pilotnetz 10 server-send-events auch gesehen habe ich nicht ausprobiert
Ja, einfach für es gehen.
Wenn es etwas ist, in dem du wirklich interessiert bist,
Und die besten Leute sind die, die sich auf IT und Programmieren interessieren und private Dinge wie GitHub-Projekte machen.
Für die guten Leute ist es mehr als nur ein Job.
Wenn ihr mich seht, bin ich hier am Computer und streame Programmierungen und arbeite von
tuesday to friday es atmen
musst du eigentlich oft mit ihnen auf der arbeit englisch reden ja das kommt
relativ oft vor allerdings sind es nicht in der sondern
Das war eine ganze Zeit lang Franzosen.
Die wir hatten, weil wir eine Software von denen gekauft haben.
Und jetzt sind es welche aus London.
Ich muss sagen, mit den Franzosen war das nice.
Das waren Schweizer Franzosen.
Und die haben sich halt auch Mühe gegeben.
Was man gar nicht so gewohnt ist normal.
Future of System Integration.
Nach der Ausbildung, nach dem Unterricht, nennt sich niemand mehr Systemintegration.
Die Jobs haben Namen wie System Engineer oder Linux Engineer oder Site Reliability Engineer.
and i think the future is that
programming and application development and administration have a lot more overlap
In den letzten 10 Jahren ist es sich mehr zusammengefasst.
Und auch neue Jobs, neue Jobtitel wie die DevOps-Maschinen.
Ich weiß nicht, was die, was die Bereich ist, in der Sie interessiert sind.
Ich mache meistens Linux-Dinge.
Mit ein bisschen Programmierung, viel, viel Automatisierung.
scripting and i don't like windows i don't do any window administrating windows administration stuff
i only use windows on my desktop and on my notebook
and on my notebook only because my employer wants that i use windows
In my last job I had the privilege to use Linux Notebook, but in my new job it's Windows only.
Ja, mit dem Recall, ist Recall nicht das, was dir dein Desktop screenshottet alle zwei Sekunden oder so?
So Leute, ich geh mir jetzt was zu essen machen, ich hab Hunger.
Ja Adam, I wish you good luck.
And that you will find a job.
Ich mach mich vom Acker, Leute.
Schön, dass ihr dabei wart.
Vier Stunden.
Und wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut.
Bis dann.
See you.